mittwoch 20 15 bei phoenix
[Musik]
so wächst
deutschland vor der wahl
[Musik]
wer will dass sich der nächste kanzler
der bundesrepublik deutschland werde der
bus auch seine beiden kreuze am sonntag
bei der spd machen erneuern wir
deutschland gemeinsam nutzen wir diesen
historischen moment und schaffen einen
echten auf der klimaschutz gerechtigkeit
und ein starkes europa ich bitte um ihr
vertrauen der nächste bundeskanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland werden zu
können
und einer der drei wird merkels
nachfolger im bundeskanzleramt doch
zunächst geht es heute abend darum
welche partei mehr stimmen von den
wählenden bekommt und wer deutschland
hier vertreten darf im deutschen
bundestag und genau von hier berichten
wir für sie heute abend an diesem hoch
spannenden wahlabend und damit herzlich
willkommen zur phoenix wahlsendung mein
name ist eva lindenau freuen sie sich
jetzt auf interessante interviews alle
zahlen und spannende gäste bei mir und
bei meiner kollegin michaela kolster
vielen dank ich begrüße sie sehr
herzlich bei phoenix den ganzen
nachmittag und abend verliehen genau hat
es gerade gesagt berichten wir über die
wahl zum zwanzigsten deutschen bundestag
zahlen fakten reaktionen interviews und
analysen haben wir für sie vorbereitet
damit sie sich wie immer das ganze bild
machen können
im laufe des tages haben die spitzen
kandidatinnen und kandidaten bereits
jeweils in ihren wohnorten ihre stimme
abgegeben haben laschet armin laschet
heute morgen in aachen nebst ehefrau
suzanne und
annalena baerbock in potsdam gab ihre
stimme allerdings ohne begleitung ab und
ebenfalls in potsdam denn dort ist auch
sein wahlkreis olaf scholz
gut fünf wochen lang tot sein intensiver
wahlkampf im lande mit höhen und tiefen
mit überraschungen und enttäuschungen da
ist der kandidat armin laschet dem man
schon als kanzler sa und der dann tief
fiel wir sahen eine kandidatin annalena
baerbock die die erwartungen an die
grünen nicht erfüllen konnte und einen
kandidaten olaf scholz der hoch flog
aber letztendlich doch an grenzen stößt
gestern nahmen die kandidatinnen und die
kandidaten noch einmal alle kraft
zusammen und riefen zum
wahlkampfabschluss mein kollege karl
hinterleitner hat das bemerkenswerteste
zusammengefasst die größte bühne hatte
armin laschet auftritt mit der kanzlerin
in aachen nicht immer waren sich in der
vergangenheit alle ganz sicher ob
merkels unterstützung für laschet
wirklich von herzen kommt
2017 vor vier jahren vier monaten und 13
tagen waren wir auch hier auf diesem
platz einen tag vor der landtagswahl
alle haben gesagt ob das gutgeht damals
war angela merkel genau hier und ich bin
sicher weil sie heute wieder ist wird es
auch morgen gelingen die cdu als
stärkste politische kraft
[Applaus]
der direkte konkurrent ums kanzleramt
gut gelaunt olaf scholz zeitgleich in
potsdam sein wahlkampfteam kaum besser
laufen können deutliche gewinne in
diesem jahr und im sommer überholte die
spd die union in seiner rede stellt olaf
scholz soziale themen in den mittelpunkt
kinderarmut wohnungsnot und den
mindestlohn
habe ich immer dafür eingesetzt dass
deutschland einen mindestlohn bekommt
weil ich einfach zu viele kenne und
kennen gelernt haben zu wenig verdienen
und ich möchte das hier jetzt noch mal
einen großen schritt machen und dafür
sorgen dass dem investor den wir heute
in deutschland haben nach oben gesetzt
wird dass er auf zwölf euro angehoben
wird
nur einen steinwurf entfernt scholz
direkte wahlkreis konkurrentin in
potsdam annalena baerbock bundesweit
führte die grünen-chefin das trio in den
umfragen einmal an jetzt werden sie und
ihre partei wohl aller voraussicht nach
auf platz drei landet werburg noch
einmal mit dem grünen kernthemen
wir haben in der pandemie aber auch in
den wahlkampf überall gespielt dass
menschen sagen wir können das doch mit
dem klimaschutz vor ort wir können
bessere kitas und schulen schaffen im
gesundheitsbereich sind pflegerinnen und
pfleger über sich hinausgewachsen und
dieser wunsch nach einer erneuerung
darum geht es jetzt am sonntag her dass
zu wählen um mit voller kraft eine neue
bundesregierung einzudringen es war die
letzte show down der drei kandidierenden
im wahlkampf der damit jetzt endgültig
vorbei ist und
wie immer bei wahlen sind unsere phoenix
korrespondenten in den parteizentralen
vor ort ich begrüße als erstes gerd
joachim von verlor im konrad adenauer
haus der cdu gab es noch mitte des
jahres weil man bei der union sicher
dass nach 16 jahren angela merkel armin
laschet der neue kanzler wird
zwischendurch war das ja in weite ferne
gerückt jetzt nach dem kopf an kopf
rennen aus die union also ein bisschen
zwischen hoffen und bangen
die hoffnung stirbt bekanntlich zuletzt
eins ist jetzt schon klar die union will
große verluste einen fragen die große
frage ist nur wird sie vor der spd
einkommen oder nicht kann sie den
kommenden kanzler stellen oder hat sie
zumindest die theoretische option mit
verhandlungen bis dahin zu bringen dass
dann am schluss armin laschet ins
kanzleramt einzieht 1 ist ja klar man
verliert natürlich mit angela merkel das
zugpferd der letzten vier wahlen und
auch viele wähler die weniger die
cdu/csu als vielmehr angela merkel als
person gewählt haben aber es ist auch so
dass natürlich das unwürdige gezerre um
den kandidaten hier eine wichtige rolle
spielt zunächst gab es eine
demokratische abstimmung in der cdu da
hat sich armin laschet durchgesetzt
gegen seine beiden kontrahenten märz
konnte röttgen aber viele der fans von
merz und röttgen sind dann nicht mehr
mit gezogen mit dem kandidaten laschet
und dann kam es natürlich auch zu dem
gezerre um die kanzlerkandidatur
mit markus s am schluss spielte ein
machtwort des bundestags präsidentin
wolfgang schäuble eine rolle und laschet
wurde durchgeboxt das haben viele andere
übel genommen so dass am schluss wenn
man strich drunter macht ist eine partei
gegeben hat die für ihren kandidaten
nicht wirklich überzeugt gekämpft hat
angela merkel immerhin die
bundeskanzlerin weiß was auf dem spiel
steht sie hat sich am ende des
wahlkampfs noch mal massiv eingemischt
und armin laschet hat gesagt es ist eine
richtungswahl kampf wenn es für rot rot
grün geben kann rein rechnerisch dann
wird olaf scholz auch rot rot grün
machen darum geht es bei dieser wahl
sagt armin laschet aber in der tat hier
im adenauer-haus guckt man gespannt auf
das endergebnis
und wenn es dann nicht reichen sollte
dann bleibt abzuwarten was hier heute
morgen oder in den kommenden tagen
passieren wird und damit zurück zu
michaela kolster vielen dank gaerte und
ich begrüße nun meinen kollegen erhard
scherfer im willy brandt haus als olaf
scholz als kanzlerkandidat vorgestellt
wurde da gab es ja sogar die diskussion
ob die spd überhaupt einen
kanzlerkandidaten aufstellen sollte das
hat sich im laufe des wahlkampfs dann
doch sehr gründlich gewandelt und
zwischenzeitlich sah es sogar nach einem
klaren sieg für olaf scholz aus das ist
jetzt einem kopf an kopf rennen gewesen
wenn man den umfragen ergebnissen
glauben darf trotzdem wie euphorisiert
ist man denn bei den sozialdemokraten
na ja ich sag mal so euphorie ist bei
der sozialdemokratie ja seit mindestens
16 jahren in aller regel ein fremdwort
und nach dem rasanten aufstieg und dem
ebenso tiefen fall von martin schulz
jedenfalls in den verglichen mit den
umfragewerten und den späteren
ergebnissen möchte ich sagen sogar ein
tabu was das thema euphorie angeht und
entsprechend ist man hier auch in den
letzten wochen und die in den letzten
monaten auch vorgegangen er mit großer
nüchternheit dass diese umfrage zahlen
angeht mit großer demut so hat es der
kanzlerkandidat auch wiederholt
formuliert man wolle er dann schon
erstmal abwarten was die wählerinnen und
wähler dann tatsächlich machen am
heutigen tag in diesem fall und insofern
hat man also diese zahlen eher mit
vorsicht begegnet als dass man sie
gefeiert hätte und keine euphorie also
auf der anderen seite aber doch eine
gewisse zufriedenheit und auch eine
gewisse genugtuung darüber dass die spd
wieder oben mitgespielt hat in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten und
es hat dann eben auch als zeichen nach
innen insofern gewirkt als dass es sich
doch die arbeit gelohnt hat in den
vergangenen jahren also nochmal
zusammengefasst keine euphorie aber
heute zumindest ein großes hoffen dass
man oben mit dabei ist und
möglicherweise auch wieder was bewegen
kann aber das werden wir erst in ein
zwei stunden wissen vielen dank erhard
scherfer und ich begrüße nun meine
kollegin jeanette klag bei den grünen in
der columbiahalle in berlin tempelhof es
gab zeiten da führte annalena baerbock
das trio der kanzlerkandidaten ja sogar
an doch jetzt sieht es eher nach einem
platz drei aus haben die grünen ihre
hochfliegenden pläne zu einer
kanzlerschaft schon ganz ad acta gelegt
naja zumindest hat die grüne
kanzlerkandidatin annalena baerbock beim
wahlkampfabschluss am freitag noch mal
den anspruch der grünen bekräftigt die
künftige bundesregierung an führen zu
wollen also nach außen bleiben die
grünen unerschütterlich bis zuletzt bei
dieser darstellung tatsächlich und das
dient natürlich auch ein bisschen der
grünen selbstvergewisserung auch der
motivation der menschen vor ort der
wahlkämpfer denn im wahlkampf war ja
nicht alles glatt gelaufen
zwischenzeitlich sind die
beliebtheitswerte und die umfragewerte
für die grüne kandidatin und auch für
die partei dramatisch eingebrochen durch
eigene fehler zuletzt hatte sich die
partei dann wieder etwas gefangen und
man hofft gerade auf den letzten metern
noch ein bisschen was gutzumachen
da hat natürlich geholfen und auftrag
gegeben dass freies for future kurz vor
diesem wochenende noch mal zu einem
globalen klima streik aufgerufen hatte
also tatsächlich hier hieß es kein
wanken im wahlkampf-endspurt das war
hier die devise auch wenn die umfragen
das glauben nicht viele hier glauben
machen dass man noch das kanzleramt
erreichen könnte natürlich die grünen
die bereiten sich aber auch auf einen
möglichen platz drei vor das hat man ja
zuletzt schon gesehen dass sie durchaus
signale gesandt hatten richtung spd die
schnittmengen betont hatten zwischen
grünen und spd und natürlich bereitet
man sich deswegen darauf vor also für
die grünen geht es heute mutmaßlich um
eine gute ausgangsposition für mögliche
koalitionsverhandlungen nicht so weit
hinter cdu und spd aber mit deutlichem
abstand vor der fdp und damit zurück ans
wahl satin den reichstag vielen dank
jeanette klag und wir gehen weiter zur
fdp ins hans dietrich genscher haus dort
ist meine kollegin katharina kühn
katharina gute stabile werte werden der
fdp prognostiziert so um die zwölf
prozent kann es durchaus werden das ist
ein guter wert für die liberalen und
viele sehen bei der fdp eine
schlüsselposition für mögliche
koalitionen sehen dass die liberalen vor
ort auch so sieht man sich schon in
einer regierung und dann stellt sich ja
die frage in welcher überhaupt
ja man sieht sich ganz klar in einer
regierung man sieht sich in der
verantwortung einen linksruck zu
verhindern so nennt das die fdp mann
will in eine regierung unter hat sich
parteichef christian sind noch sehr
schnell festgelegt jamaika ist sein
favorit auch von anderen fdp-politiker
aber ganz ausschließen will man die
ampel ja doch nicht auch wenn das
gefordert wurde auch wenn christian
lindner auch immer wieder sagt ihm fehle
die fantasie für eine regierung mit spd
und grünen
man will ja auch nicht nur
steigbügelhalter für die cdu seien und
es ist ja auch strategisch schlauer wenn
man denn in mögliche koalitionsgespräche
geht dass man dann noch eine zweite
option in der hand hat und damit zurück
zu michaela kolster vielen dank
katharina kühn und mein kollege
alexander keller ist bei der afg in
kaulsdorf das ist ziemlich im osten der
stadt alexander zulegen wird die partei
nach den umfragen wohl nicht ist der
höhenflug der afg damit gestoppt und
wenn ja woran liegt das
michaela kolster mit den umfragen für
die afg oder über die afd ist das so
eine sache bei den demoskopen daher
viele bei den umfragen nicht zugeben
wollen dass die afg wählen weil die
wahlergebnisse hinten auch immer etwas
besser aus als die umfragen dass
vorhergesagt haben deswegen werden diese
umfragen jetzt auch anders gewichtet
sollten die umfragen recht behalten dass
die afg glatt unter der selbst gesetzten
messlatte von 12,6 prozent letzte
bundestagswahl durch springen würden
dann wäre das sicherlich ein herber
rückschlag für die partei wenn es so
käme ursachen sind eigentlich zwei zu
nennen einmal das zerwürfnis zwischen
dem sogenannten gemäßigten und dem
radikalen flügel der partei und die
themen der bundestagswahl 2021 die war
nun gar nicht nach dem geschmack der afg
gewesen vor vier jahren stand ganz oben
auf der agenda noch das thema
flüchtlinge jetzt sind es corona klima
soziale gerechtigkeit keine leib und
magen themen der partei insofern würde
man damit dann auch erklären wenn es
nicht so gut gelaufen ist das
wahlergebnis ist für die partei sehr
sehr wichtig denn eigentlich geht es
danach erst richtig los denn man
erwartet ja spätestens auf dem parteitag
im dezember in wiesbaden einen showdown
und je nachdem wie die wahl jetzt
ausgeht wird die eine oder die andere
seite dann daraus eben argumente ziehen
um diesen showdown diesen machtkampf für
sich zu entscheiden das ist im moment
noch alles spekulation nicht so sehr der
wahlkampf und das wahlergebnis heute
abend entscheiden sondern die
konsequenzen die man daraus zieht eine
sache steht jetzt schon absolut sicher
die afg oder mit der afg will niemand
koalieren deswegen kann man es hier für
den abend auch etwas gelassener angehen
lassen das war der erste wasserstand
hier aus kaulsdorf zurück ins felix
wahlstudio vielen dank alexander kähler
und wir gehen jetzt zu den linken meine
kollegin katja fuchs begrüße ich dort im
festsaal in berlin-kreuzberg hat ja die
linke banken noch ein wenig um die fünf
prozent hürde besonders im osten hat die
partei probleme dort wo sie eigentlich
jahrelang volkspartei war und in
thüringen ja sogar den
ministerpräsidenten stellt ausgerechnet
da sind massive verluste zu erwarten
warum vertraut
ostdeutschland der linken nicht mehr um
vielleicht ihre probleme auch
tatsächlich anzupacken
da sind vor allen dingen drei sachen
ursächlich für die linke als partei aus
dem osten war immer die partei der
unzufriedenen die protestpartei die
partie partei die sich um diejenigen
gekümmert hat die eben 40 vergessen
gefühlt haben aber auch die linke wurde
mit der zeit immer etablierter und das
war genau das problem denn viele
ostdeutsche hatten das gefühl dass die
linken nicht mehr für ihre interessen
eintritt und ein großer knackpunkt war
2015 als es um die flüchtlinge und die
debatte ging da haben viele ostdeutsche
gehofft dass die linke sich vor ihn
stellt ihre sorgen ihre nöte rund um das
thema zuwanderung ernst nimmt und haben
da auch vorgeworfen dass sie sich nicht
genau positioniert hat stattdessen hat
den partnern eine andere partei
übernommen und zwar die afg die seitdem
auch sehr viele wählerinnen und wähler
stimmen der linken ab 1 der zweite grund
ist die bröckelnde struktur innerhalb
der linken die linke hat eine sehr alte
mitgliederschaft und sehr alte
wählerinnen und wähler das gros ist über
70 jahre alt und es rücken wenige junge
menschen nach und die jungen wählerinnen
und wähler die teilen sich die linken
jetzt auch zunehmend mit den grünen und
zuletzt die vielstimmigkeit mit der die
partei die vergangenen jahre
argumentiert hat es fehlte der fokus der
fokus vor allen dingen auf die menschen
im osten es wurde zwar immer wieder ost
west angleichung gesprochen aber die
partei hat sich eben auch in den westen
geöffnet und viele ostdeutsche die haben
mir das doch übel genommen weil sie
gesagt haben ihr habt uns vergessen wir
werden mal sehr gespannt sein was um 18
uhr die zahlen wirklich dann ergeben
katja fuchs und last but not least sind
wir auch in münchen fort ich begrüße
meinen kollegen hans werner fittkau in
der csu-parteizentrale für die csu war
es nach der nominierung von armin
laschet ja klar der kanzlerkandidat der
herzen ist markus söder ist die
enttäuschung über die prognostizierten
zahlen dazu spüren denn auch für die csu
sind die zahlen ja nicht ganz einfach
sondern ihr schlecht
ja das wird ein spannender abend auf
jeden fall mal für die csu unter kanzler
kandidat der herzen der selbsternannte
kanzler kandidat der herzen hat heute
bekannt er war sei nicht nervös ist also
ein bisschen angespannt also ich an
seiner stelle wäre durchaus nervös denn
armin laschet ist ja in bayern bei den
csu anhängern viel viel unbeliebter als
im rest des landes und vermutlich weiß
nicht gerade hilfreich dass markus söder
ja immer wieder mit sticheleien im
wahlkampf aufgefallen ist mit
sticheleien richtung armin laschet und
das sein generalsekretär markus blume
drei wochen vor der wahl noch in einem
spiegel interview gesagt hat also markus
söder wir sicher der bessere kandidat
gewesen war mit sicherheit auch nicht
hilfreich will sagen die csu muss
befürchten dass sie unter 30 prozent
sinkt sie kommt von 38,8 bei der
letzten bundestagswahl deshalb erzielt
hier in bayern und ist damit über die
fünf-prozent-hürde gekommen es gibt hier
das szenario und die befürchtung dass es
diesmal anders wird dass die csu mit den
zwei stimmen nicht mal über die fünf
prozent hürde kommt sondern nur mit
hilfe der gewonnenen direktkandidaten
übrigens gestandene wahlkämpfer haben
hier in bayern berichtet aus dem
wahlkampf für die csu dass die leute
ihnen an den infoständen auf den
marktplätzen gesagt haben also euch
wählen wir diesmal nicht und dann haben
die direktkandidaten darum gebeten
jedenfalls der eine oder andere dann
bitte gebt uns doch wenigstens die
erststimme also das wird ja ein
schwieriger abend für die csu wenn die
ergebnisse so aussehen wie die prognosen
wir sind hier übrigens in der kantine
der landeszentrale der csu der zentrale
der csu hier in bayern
die zutaten für einen sehr spannenden
abend sind also beisammen wollen wir
schauen was ihr heute abend so
aufgetischt wird und damit zurück zu
michaela kolster nach berlin vielen dank
hans werner fittkau nach münchen und ich
begrüße jetzt an meiner seite sehr
herzlich der politikwissenschaftler
herrn professor thorsten faas
politikwissenschaft seiner freien
universität hier in berlin mit dem
schwerpunkt wahlforschung und von daher
natürlich derjenige der uns hier heute
abend wunderbar begleiten kann und gut
auskunft geben kann herr falls wir haben
die korrespondenten in den parteien
gerade eben gehört wer von denen hat
denn da am meisten zu verlieren in den
batterien für die union steht natürlich
viel auf dem spiel es gilt das
kanzleramt zu verteidigen das ist der
anspruch der union an dem sich messen
lassen muss und auch selber messen
lassen wird und auch die zahlen die wir
in den umfragen gesehen haben bedeuten
natürlich darauf hin dass die union viel
zu verlieren hat und auch ein großer
verlust droht sofern wird das glaube ich
für die union wenn sich so ungefähr
bestätigt was wir vorher in umfragen
gesehen haben insgesamt ein sehr
schwieriger abend der wahlkampf war ein
eher ungewöhnlicher wahlkampf das kann
man glaube ich mit fug und recht sagen
für politikwissenschaftler bestimmt ein
weites feld dieses im anschluss auch zu
analysieren da gibt es bestimmt viele
arbeiten dazu was war denn so anders
warum war der wahlkampf so anders als
wir sonst vor allen dingen in den
letzten legislaturperioden so gewohnt
waren was war anders
ganz ganz viel woanders natürlich die
pandemie die erstmal den rahmen gesetzt
hat und die auch für die art des
wahlkampf führen natürlich konsequenzen
gehabt hat die für die art der
stimmabgabe konsequenzen gab dann wenn
wir heute davon reden dass sie
unglaublich viele menschen briefwahl
machten dann liegt es ja eben auch daran
dass die pandemie eben bestimmte
verhaltensweisen geändert hat wir suchen
eine nachfolgerin für angela merkel der
erste wahlkampf ohne amtsinhaberin auch
das völlig neu wir haben eine völlig
unklare koalitionslager auch völlig neu
trainer hatten wir die wir in dieser
form auch noch nicht hatten und das sind
nur ein paar beispiele die er wirklich
zeigen dass dies ein wahlkampf in einer
politischen situation gewesen ist und
bis heute ist der wirklich ungewöhnlich
ist und der vielleicht sogar ein stück
weit eine zeitenwende für die deutsche
politik bedeuten kann bei vieles von dem
werden wir nicht nur einmal erlebt haben
dreierbündnisse etc sondern das könnte
uns dann ganz so weiter noch begleiten
zu der zeitenwende werden wir heute
abend sicherlich noch öfter kommen wenn
wir uns den wahlkampf genauer anschauen
geht ja immer darum inhalte oder
personen das war glaube ich ein sehr
personen geprägter wahlkampf inhalte gab
es ja eigentlich genug wir haben das
thema klima krise bei den grünen vor
allem natürlich das thema wir haben aber
auch eine corona pandemie wir haben eine
flutkatastrophe gehabt und wir haben
auch noch afghanistan gehabt warum sind
diese themen letztendlich dann gar nicht
mal so den vordergrund gekommen sondern
warum waren es vor allem die personen
dieser um vordergrund standen wenn man
sich die politische agenda anguckt hat
man erst mal sehr deutlichen wandel
gesehen corona war wirklich über 15 18
monate ein absolut dominantes thema und
noch dazu ein etwas natürlich
parteipolitisch auch nicht einfach ist
weil es kein thema gewesen ist mit dem
man leicht wahlkampf führen kann ähnlich
auch afghanistan was kurzzeitig die
agenda dominiert hat was aber auch eben
angesichts der thematik einfach
schwierig ist und die anderen themen
klar klimawandel ein drängendes thema
für viele menschen es gab aber auch ein
paar umfragen die gezeigt haben das
klima war als nationales problem gesehen
wird das aber für viele menschen im
einzelnen tatsächlich auch themen der
sozialen gerechtigkeit der pflege
beispielsweise sehr wichtige themen
gewesen sind im wahlkampf ist punktuell
darüber gesprochen aber sie haben
vollkommen recht wir haben sehr sehr
viel über personen geredet das ist der
nachfolge merkel sicherlich ein stück
weit geschuldet und letztlich ist es
immer das paket ich kann keine inhalte
ohne person verkaufen ich kann aber auch
nicht wirklich eine person ohne inhalt
verkaufen insofern ist vielleicht eine
frage der balance am ende manchmal mir
sehr sehr viel über sehr kleinteiliges
gesprochen das ist sicher richtig aber
wir wollen natürlich auch wissen wer die
kanzlerin der kanzler den nächsten vier
jahren sollen selber schauen wir noch
mal auf die zahlen der letzten
legislaturperiode
2017 haben wir zahlen für sie
vorbereitet die cdu ist damals auf 2 146
sitze gekommen die spd auf 153 die afg
auf 94 die liberalen auf 80 die linke
960 und die kleinste fraktion war damals
man glaubt das heute gar nicht mehr mit
67 stimmen waren dass die grünen es gab
eine große koalition sie sagten schon
das wird eine zeitenwende werden ist es
auch deshalb weil die bilanz der großen
koalition dann auch so ist dass man den
eindruck hatte jetzt stillstand jetzt
muss irgendwas passieren na ja das ist
so ein image das der groko in der tat
oft angehängt wird aber wenn man die
legislaturperiode insgesamt sich
anschaut dann haben wir wirklich auch
höhen und tiefen dieser großen koalition
erlebt man vergisst so ein wenig wie
schwierig der staat eigentlich gewesen
ist das gilt natürlich für die
unmittelbare zeit der gründung der groß
war eine notlösung nachdem jamaika
geplatzt ist aber die kanzlerin die
regierung auch die regierenden parteien
hatten wirklich ganz ganz schlechte
werte zu beginn dieser legislaturperiode
die pandemie hat es dramatisch geändert
plötzlich stand die union bei 40 prozent
aber das war eben nicht nachhaltig aber
trotzdem der groko obwohl sie eigentlich
eine groko ist sagt man eben oft nach
dass sie nur schwierige kompromisse hat
finden können das oft zähe kompromisse
waren nur das ehrlich gesagt könnte uns
durchaus erhalten bleiben wenn diese
dreierbündnis über die wir reden
natürlich nicht mal so eben zueinander
finden und das ist völlig klar es ist
richtig schauen wir doch mal auf zahlen
nämlich auf die letzten die die
forschungsgruppe wahlen am freitag
herausgegeben hat für die sonntagsfrage
da ist deutlich zu sehen dass die
parteien sich sehr annähern nach
ergebnissen war die union bei 23 die spd
bei 25 die fdp bei 10 die fdp bei 11 die
linke bei 6 und die grünen bei 16 5 wenn
man sich das anschaut dann sind die
parteien sehr nah aneinander also da
gibt es keinen strahlenden sieger ist
das auch eine konsequenz der großen
koalition ja sicherlich auch wobei wir
einfach auch für einzelne parteien
immense höhen und tiefen in dieser
legislaturperiode erlebt haben die fw
die spd stand teilweise bei 11 prozent
jetzt sehen wir werte von 25 die union
stand bei 40 zwischen partizan meine 19
also eigentlich hat volatilität diese
beweglichkeit dynamik diese
legislaturperiode geprägt und das gilt
bis zum heutigen tag denn wir haben eine
große unsicherheit die wir alle so
spüren und blick auf diese umfragen
eigentlich sind sie immer sehr gut in
deutschland aber dann merkte so dass in
anhalt verhalten wäre eigentlich das
gibt sich ja immer mal wieder beispiele
wo dann auf der zielgerade was passiert
und gerade sachsen anhalt ist ein gutes
beispiel warum ist dort was passiert
weil wir eigentlich der erwartung hatten
das auf der basis von umfragen
wohlgemerkt ein kopf-an-kopf-rennen
bevorstehen würde zwischen der cdu und
der ard das wollten viele wählerinnen
und wähler nicht und haben sich dann
wirklich in den allerletzten metern auf
den allerletzten metern umentschieden
das kann immer passieren
insofern haben auch heute noch viel
spannung hier glaube ich zu besprechen
für den moment vielen dank herr
verfasser fast denn wir haben neben dem
bundestag ja auch noch zwei
gleichzeitige landtagswahlen heute eine
davon in mecklenburg vorpommern ich
begrüße vor dem schweriner schloss in
dem der landtag ja beheimatet ist meine
kollegin constanze adac konstante
manuela schwesig liegt in umfragen weit
vorne das war aber auch ein stück weit
zu erwarten oder
ja das kann man so sagen sowie manuela
schwesig hier die ihre rolle der
landesmutter hineingewachsen ist csd ja
eigentlich die unangefochtene königin
von mecklenburg vorpommern wenn die
leute hier im lande dürften dann würden
zwei drittel von ihnen sie persönlich
sofort als neue ministerpräsidentin
wählen dürfen sie aber nicht im moment
sind die umfragen wahnsinnig hoch in
prozenten ausgedrückt liegt sie bei
ungefähr 40 prozent manche sehen sie
sogar darüber manche ein bisschen
darunter und das ist nicht nur ein wert
der an darin spd landesfürsten das
wasser in die augen vor neid treiben
software sondern auch in bei der union
sicherlich ähnliche gefühle
herausbringen wird aber es ist auch ein
riesiger sprung hierfür mecklenburg
vorpommern lassen sie mich mit ihnen
zusammen auf die zahlen von 20 16
schauen denn da werden sie sehen da lag
er bei der letzten wahl die spd bei 30,6
jetzt eben wie gesagt zehn prozent mehr
20,8 also fast 21 ist die afd hoch
gehüpft damals im sie ringt auch
weiterhin mit der cdu um platz zwei die
prognosen sehen sie jetzt tiefer so um
die 15 bis 18 wir haben aber ja schon
gehört dass gerade da die prognose nicht
unbedingt so aussagekräftig sind die die
cdu lag damals noch bei 19 prozent das
wäre schön wenn sie sie bekommen würde
15 prozent ist so der allgemeine
gewährte das könnte aber auch darunter
liegen und 13,2 die linke jetzt dümpelt
diese ungefähr bei 10 11 prozent grüne
und fdp sind damals nicht in den landtag
hineingekommen dies könnten die jetzt
wieder schaffen aber die kapseln so ein
bisschen beide an der fünf prozent hürde
das wird also eine spannende wahl hier
kommt rein und das wird auch deswegen
spannend weil man nicht so genau weiß
wie dann hier die nächste regierung
aussieht die wahrscheinliche
wahlsiegerin manuela schwesig hat sich
da im vorfeld immer sehr sehr bedeckt
gehalten und sich alle optionen offen
gehalten sie könnte wieder mit der cdu
in einer großen koalition regieren aber
auch anderes wäre möglich mit den linken
zum beispiel liefern ihr auch ja schon
mal in der regierung mit drin eventuell
wird es auch was mit der fdp oder mit
den grün also wird ein spannender abend
hier lassen sie uns noch mal zurück
gucken auf die themen dieses wahlkampfes
der wald kampf der war im grunde
genommen in erster linie eine
one-woman-show manuela schwesig hat den
auch beherrscht und sie hat mit jedem
landeskind gefühlt ein paar worte
gewechselt
sie nennt sich die frau für mv
ministerpräsidentin manuela schwesig
seit wochen macht sie straßenwahlkampf
lächelt von mehr als 1000 plakatwänden
wie die spd aufgestellt hat in der
korona pandemie vor sie einen
vergleichsweise harten kurs und steuert
nun ein rekordergebnis an
wichtig ist den menschen das für gute
arbeit mit guten löhnen haben dass wir
unseren kindern weiter eine gute bildung
geben und natürlich auch dass unsere
umwelt geschützt wird er kann jede hilfe
gebrauchen
der spitzenkandidat der cdu in
mecklenburg vorpommern und dass
kanzlerin merkel und cdu kanzlerkandidat
laschet sind gestern abend nach
stralsund gekommen um michael sack zu
unterstützen seinen schlechten umfrage-
und bekanntheitswerte doch noch einen
aufschwung zu geben er selbst greift die
konkurrenz in seinem bundesland noch mal
an es fördern 26 september passieren
dass wir ein rot-rot-grünes bündnis
bekommen und am 27
morgens früh aufwachen mit kopfschmerzen
die afg kämpft mit der cdu um platz zwei
gegen die landesregierung gegen
altersarmut und für
familienfreundlichkeit familien ausser
mutter vater kind alle parteien
schließen ein bündnis mit der afg aus
die linke kämpft mit der
spitzenkandidatin und ehemaligen
schuldirektor in simone oldenburg für
bessere bildung zivil 1000 zusätzliche
lehrkräfte und kostenloses mittagessen
in der schule laut umfrage könnte es für
rot rot reichen die grünen versuchen mit
ihren klima positionen zu punkten und
fordern bessere kitas die fdp will das
land digitalisieren am liebsten
gemeinsam mit der cdu grüne und fdp
müssen jedoch um den wiedereinzug in den
landtag zittern
1,6 millionen menschen leben ungefähr
hier in mecklenburg vorpommern und davon
sind 1,3 millionen wahlberechtigten die
bestimmen als über das schicksal der
demnächst in dem fluss hinter mir unten
sitzt und regiert und in schwerin der
landeshauptstadt wo dieses schöne
schloss steht da wohnen nur acht 90.000
menschen das ist die kleinste
landeshauptstadt überhaupt von ganz
deutschland in der grössten die teile
menschen lebt eben den kleineren orten
in kleinen städten auf dem lande und
genau dort haben sich unsere kollegen
getan und gefragt was die menschen denn
eigentlich von den politikern und
politikerinnen erwarten enttäuscht
ziemlich politikverdrossen wenn man so
große sprüche dass er das kann sich
ändern dürfen sich aber meine verpassen
wir trotzdem jetzt schon früher das war
nicht alles schlecht gewesen so was halt
gleich so wie es ist ganz entscheidend
der sache ist einfach wir das jetzt
langsam mit dem co2 auf die reihe
kriegen oder mich und ihn traurig dass
ich dagegen die jungen leute die shuttle
mitunter mit dem kopf und wissen nicht
was sie machen sollen jedenfalls ist die
politik immer noch interessant
thema manchmal das blabla auch nicht
mehr hören kann aber bleibt interessant
viele sind sehr orientierung der allein
gehen auch wenn man sich die bildung
hier eben halt mal anschaut die schuhe
hin dass das funktioniert alles
irgendwie nicht das ist halt so dass
große probleme
der große probleme vor einer
wundervollen kulisse hier in schwerin
ich begrüße hier jemand der dieses land
sehr sehr gut kennt ja einmal als
arbeitgeber präsident aber auch als
vorsitzender des deutschen hotel- und
gaststättengewerbe ist hier in
mecklenburg vorpommern nach schwarz
herzlich willkommen bei phoenix ländern
eher schwarz eine harte zeit hinter sich
gehabt in einer zeit in mecklenburg
vorpommern ist ja die tourismusregion
nummer eins genau das kann man so sagen
sieben monate am stück zwangs
geschlossen beim zweiten lockdown das
macht natürlich für das tourismusland
mecklenburg-vorpommern ist tourismusland
nummer eins ist das natürlich ein ganz
ganz harter schlag gewesen von dem wir
uns immer noch nicht erholt haben das
heißt die umsätze sind eingebrochen
kommen sie überhaupt noch wieder daran
an die vor corinna zeiten oder wie lange
wird das dauern wir haben eigentlich
einen ganz guten sommer letztes jahr
schon gehabt nach dem ersten lockdown
auch in diesem jahr sieht der sommer gut
aus allerdings sind wir natürlich
deutlich verspätet gestartet konnten das
ostergeschäft nicht mitnehmen konnten
vingst nicht mitnehmen sind auch später
gestartet als andere bundesländer
versuchen jetzt natürlich einiges
aufzuholen aber nochmal sieben monate am
stück zwangs geschlossen zu sein auch
mitarbeiter haben unseren betrieben den
rücken gekehrt das kriegen wir nicht
aufgeholt und die dunkle jahreszeit also
wirklich die sechs monate die jetzt vor
uns liegen schwache umsätze die müssen
wir dann tatsächlich irgendwie überleben
wir sind saison betriebe und
dementsprechend sind wir noch nicht über
den berg was erwarten sie denn jetzt von
der neuen regierung ja erstmal
verlässlichkeit also wir haben in der
krise das muss man wirklich sagen wir
haben sehr gut auch wenn wir mit
sicherheit nicht immer einer meinung
waren sehr gut mit der landesregierung
zusammengearbeitet hat einen sehr
direkten draht und erhoffen uns und
fordern natürlich auch dass wir wieder
eine stabile regierung kriegen erst mal
in schwerin und dass wir auch eine
verlässlichkeit kriegen das virtuelle
verlässlichkeit auch an der sinne dass
sie wissen wo sie hin steuern oder wie
es weitergeht mit der öffnung oder genau
dass wir einfach den guten zugang den
wir uns jetzt glaube wir haben ja alle
in einem boot gesessen in der krise und
sehr sehr eng abgestimmt dass wir im
prinzip dieses vertrauensvolle
verhältnis weiter auch bewahren können
dann wenn ich das ein oder andere
wahlprogramm hier durchlesen da muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen dann fühle ich mich
als unternehmer schon
sag ich mal so ein bisschen in die
falsche ecke aber die spitzenfrau die
wird ja die spitze frau bleiben wenn er
sich etwas ganz ganz anderes passiert
also insofern da fühlen sie sich glaube
ich ganz guten händen oder
wie gesagt also die wahlprogramme sind
schon sehr unterschiedlich das muss man
sagen und ist stolz von 12 euro ist
lassen sich jetzt 14 auf den mindestlohn
aber auch teilweise auf mehr kontrolle
und mehr also das bild was so ein
wahlprogramm dann auch von einer
unternehmerin oder ein unternehmer
beschreibt das stört uns dann an der
einen oder anderen stelle und von der
sache her hoffe ich tatsächlich wenn
wahlkampf durch ist dass wir wieder eine
verlässliche regierung bekommen die dann
auch sag mal in der mitte angesiedelt
ist und das vor allem auch eine
wirtschaftspolitische ausrichtung da ist
und auch wirtschaftspolitischer
sachverstand weil ohne die
unternehmerinnen unternehmer wird es
nicht gehen ja der wahlkampf ist zu ende
die wahl fast gelaufen lars schwarz
herzlichen danke für den blick zurück
aber insbesondere für den voraus
herzlichen dank für den besuch hier bei
uns am set ja das war dieser erste
kurzer eindruck hier aus dem mecklenburg
vorpommern es geht zurück nach berlin
zum michaela kolster
vielen dank an konstanzer bratzke in
schwerin neben mecklenburg vorpommern
wählt heute auch berlin ein neues
abgeordnetenhaus zwölf neue
bezirksparlamente und außerdem können
die berlinerinnen und berliner in einem
volksentscheid darüber abstimmen ob
große wohnungsbaukonzern zukünftig
enteignet werden können eine ganze menge
also zu entscheiden in berlin und ich
grüße meine kollegin ines arland im
berliner abgeordnetenhaus ihnen ist laut
umfragen liegt die spd mit der
spitzenkandidatin franziska gefallen die
wir auch aus dem bund kennen vorne trotz
nachgewiesener plagiate in ihren
abschlussarbeiten wie groß sind denn
ihre chancen tatsächlich regierende
bürgermeisterin zu werden
das ist zumindestens aus berliner sicht
michaela kolster hier die 100.000 euro
frage dieses abends diplomatisch würde
man zu diesem zeitpunkt weit vor 18 uhr
antworten sie hat zumindest gute chancen
und liegt nach den umfragen tatsächlich
ziemlich weit vorn im bewerberfeld
natürlich weiß jeder diese wahl ist ja
eine wahl im windschatten dieser große
aber sie ist nicht unspannend denn die
berliner sind durchaus bekannt für
überraschungen immer mal für eine
überraschung gut bis 14 uhr haben hier
übrigens 27,4 prozent der
wahlberechtigten das sind 2,4 millionen
insgesamt ihre stimme abgegeben aber
auch hier wie überall in deutschland
eine relativ hohe zahl an briefwählern
fast eine millionen briefwahlunterlagen
sind angefordert worden das bedeutet
also hohe herausforderung für das was
dann an auszählen zu machen ist und es
gab auch einige kleine pannen es gab
lange schlangen vor den wahllokalen hier
und in einigen wahllokalen sind sogar
die stimmzettel ausgegangen also dass
immer ein bisschen rund laufen hier in
berlin aber man ist auch gewohnt zu
improvisieren schauen wir mal auf die
ausgangslage so wie man 20 16 aus den
wahlen rausgegangen ist damals wurde
übrigens am 18 september gewählt damals
lag die spd von allerdings mit starken
verlusten 21,6 die cdu mit 17,6 hatte
ebenfalls verloren die grünen sind bei
15,2 angekommen die linke bei 15,6 die
afg aus dem stand auf 14,2 haben sehr
viele mandate geholt und die fdp bei 6,7
die waren zurückgekehrt ins
abgeordnetenhaus die wir also heute dort
landen werden werden wir sehen eines
bleibt über den abend spannend es wird
keine frühe entscheidung geben und es
gibt tatsächlich einige leute die sich
hoffnungen machen können auf den sessel
im roten rathaus genau zwei frauen und
ein mann haben gute oder beste chancen
je nachdem wie man es formulieren möchte
das sind zum einen sie haben es genannt
franziska gefahr die ehemalige
bundesfamilienministerin das ist aber
auch bettina jarasch die grüne
spitzenkandidatin wird sich in augsburg
die man vorher noch gar nicht so stark
hier wahrgenommen hatte in berlin und es
ist kein gegner den man zum beispiel
auch aus dem deutschen bundestag kennt
dort ist ja noch abgeordneter der
spitzenkandidat
cdu die sozialdemokraten liegt auch noch
in letzten umfragen vorn aber eben
berlin ist immer für eine überraschung
gut schauen wir auf das bewerberfeld
die letzte diskussionsrunde der berliner
spitzenkandidaten vor der wahl dominiert
von dem thema der stadt
bezahlbare wohnen ist die große soziale
frage für uns alle wir sind uns einig
dass es das wichtigste thema für unsere
stadt ist und deshalb habe ich auch ganz
klar gesagt chefin in sachen neubau und
mieten regulierung sollen das problem
lösen da sind sich alle parteien bis auf
die linke einig sie unterstützt mit
ihrem spitzenkandidaten klaus lederer
klar den volksentscheid zur enteignung
von wohnungsunternehmen
bettina jarasch spitzenkandidatin der
grünen wird zwar auch mit ja stimmen
sieht die enteignung aber nur als
letztes mittel neben dem wohnen steht
für sie der klimaschutz im mittelpunkt
wahlkampf aktion mit einem schmelzenden
eis blog
wir müssen berlin fit machen für eine
stadt im klimawandel denn da passiert ja
längst und das bedeutet wir brauchen
überall grüne oasen grüne insel
ortsbesuch bei einem startup netzwerk
cdu-spitzenkandidat kai wegner für seine
partei aus der opposition wieder an die
regierung führen auch wenn die cdu laut
umfragen zurzeit nur auf platz drei
liegt wegner will berlin sicherer machen
zb mit kameraüberwachung und den
wirtschaftsstandort stärken
berlin hat vieles was wir für startups
für gründerinnen und gründer brauchen
wir haben wissenschaft wir haben
forschungseinrichtung wir haben
entwicklung und ich glaube wir müssen
jetzt dafür sorgen dass berlin seine
stärken wieder sebastian czaja von der
fdp setzt auf weniger vorgaben für die
wirtschaft und christine brinker von der
ahr fdp mit dem thema innere sicherheit
punkten
und hier also die bewerber die sich
bemühen um das rote rathaus entweder mit
zu regiert oder tatsächlich den
chefsessel selber einzunehmen viele
klangvolle namen haben diese stadt
bereits in der vergangenheit regiert da
war willy brandt zum beispiel bei den
sozialdemokraten hans jochen vogel aber
auch klaus wowereit wenn man bei der
sozialdemokratischen seite bleiben aber
auch eberhard diepgen richard von
weizsäcker auf der cdu-seite eine der
spannendsten zeiten erwischte walter
momper der sozialdemokrat 1989 90 als
opa zu dem zeitpunkt als berlin die
freiheit neu entdeckte und die mauer
fiel ein gespräch mit ihm über gestern
heute und morgen ich habe ihn zunächst
gefragt vor wenigen minuten vor 30
jahren war ja bei die mehr oder weniger
verzückt vom sagen wir mal so der
freiheit und jetzt wäre die frage was
ist von dieser leichtigkeit tatsächlich
noch geblieben heute
übrig geblieben also ich glaub schon
eine ganze menge ist übrig geblieben
wir haben den start in die moderne
großstadt glaube ich eigentlich recht
gut geschafft in den 30 jahren wir haben
uns darin eingerichtet die stadt ist
immer noch unglaublich kreativ
allerdings hat sie auch eine menge
zukunftsprobleme da würde es ja falsch
sein das zu leugnen
die bewältigt werden müssen deshalb eine
aufgabe für die politik
was würden sie als das größte der
zukunftspläne definieren naja
vordergründig ist es natürlich die
wohnungsnot in der stadt die hohen
mieten die es unmöglich machen sich hier
anzusiedeln wenn man von außen kommt das
muss dringend gelöst werden das ist eine
aufgabe für die nächsten fünf jahre
legislaturperiode und natürlich die
klimakatastrophe und die
herausforderungen die dadurch kommen die
trifft ja die großen städte stärker als
das flache land aber hier ist da viel zu
tun und viel geld zu investieren und wir
müssen dahin kommen jeder weiß sie sind
auch unternehmerisch tätig das heißt sie
können sozusagen die dinge von beiden
dingen wir blicken und klima ist
tatsächlich ein stichwort aktuell laufen
ja hat man ein bisschen den eindruck
wettbewerbe um das schärfste klimaziel
an verschiedenen stellen also da kann
man zum beispiel in wahlprogramm aktuell
hier lesen null emission szene wie viel
und andere viele andere dinge eine
befreite innenstadt von verbrenner etc
wie viele reglementierung tut der stadt
gut ja das weiß ich auch noch nicht ganz
ich glaube eher dass vieles zur
bewältigung der klimakatastrophe letzten
endes auch selber läuft wenn nämlich die
wirtschaft insbesondere sieht dass sie
davon ganz gut leben kann aber der rest
muss natürlich öffentlich finanziert
werden und das wird große probleme
machen und das wird in der stadt noch
stärker werden als woanders wir haben
hier die höchsten emissionen ja bekannt
nicht aus der gebäudebeheizung und bis
wir die häuser alle
winterfest gemacht haben also mit
besserer wärme der wärmedämmung aus
wärmedämmung ausgestattet haben das wird
einige zeit dauern das wird viel geld
kosten
und da wird er die formel gelten ein
drittel muss der private hauseigentümer
bezahlen drittel zahlt der staat dazu
was viel geld ist und drittel müssen die
mieter bezahlen was auch sehr viel geld
ist aber ich denke das wird schon
hinkommen und das hört man schon sehen
sind die sozialdemokrat deswegen muss
man auch sagen wenn sie sagen es kostet
geld ok geld ausgeben ist immer eine
vornehme disziplin von politik aber der
verbraucher am ende sozusagen der
schlange muss ja auch noch irgendwo mit
dabei bleiben berlin ist jetzt sozusagen
nicht nur wohlstands gebiet das muss man
ganz klar sagen klimaschutz kostet auch
also am dem platz am ende hängen na ja
ungefähr drittel drittel drittel das
wird für jeden bereich genug sein das
dritte was bei der privaten
gebäudewirtschaft aber bei jeder anderen
wirtschaft auch hängen bleibt ist
natürlich sehr viel geld das dritte was
der staat finanzieren will muss im
wesentlichen wahrscheinlich aus der
neuverschuldung bezahlen ist auch sehr
viel geld und das dritte was die
mieterinnen und mieter bezahlen müssen
auf ihre miete drauf das ist auch
erheblich also das ist nicht so ganz
einfach aber ich denke man kann das
schaffen und wenn man vernünftige co2
bepreisung hat könnte man auch wieder
geld zurückbekommen was man dann an die
mieter erstattet oder an die breiten
massen also so dass das für die etwas
leichter ist als es jetzt aussieht
dieses mal ist ein besonderes mal könnte
eine zäsur werden es könnte das erste
mal eine frau auf den chefsessel
schaffen im roten rathaus
die farbe ist noch nicht ganz ausgemacht
zu diesem zeitpunkt wo wir sprechen was
muss die neue bürgermeisterin oder der
neue regierende bürgermeister als erstes
angehen aus ihrer perspektive mehr als
erstes angehen muss dann natürlich die
wohnungsnot und dafür sorgen dass mehr
gebaut wird und dafür auch mehr
wohnungen zur verfügung stehen und das
wird auch in hohem masse mit
öffentlichen mitteln geschehen weil die
mieten beim neubau einfach zu hoch sind
um dem normalbürger unterkunft zu
gewähren
das muss sie leisten das muss im
wesentlichen wie gesagt mit öffentlicher
hilfe geschehen es müssen die
städtischen wohnungsbaugesellschaften
ran die genossenschaften
schwerpunktmäßig aber auch der private
bauherr wobei die ihre wohnung schon
loswerden dass ist scheint mir das
geringste problem zu sein und dann
natürlich die klimakatastrophe auch für
die stadt anpacken und etwa für den
personennahverkehr also dass wir runter
müssen vom individualverkehr auf die
öffentlichen und das bedeutet doch
rieseninvestitionen öffentlichen verkehr
etwa eine u-bahn oder die s-bahn
herrmann bei unserer schlusspunkt berlin
möchte weiterhin bild muss man ja
einschränken als internationale
metropole
lebenswert wahrgenommen werden das ist
erstmal gut und richtig so aber welches
signal wir haben es gerade den berlin
marathon in der stadt 25.000 teilnehmer
international aber welches signal sendet
es international aus wenn wir hier
veranstalten einen volksentscheid über
den enteignung von unternehmen ja ich
habe den nicht veranstaltet andere haben
es gemacht das ist auch deren gutes
recht so etwas zu veranstalten
aber ich halte es politisch für falsch
das so zu machen
selbst wenn der volksentscheid durch
kommt was durchaus sein kann selbst dann
wird die stadt sie ewig streit mit dem
verfassungsrecht und vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht
es wird über die entschädigung
gestritten werden und das dauert und
dauert und darauf können wir überhaupt
nicht warten sondern es muss mehr gebaut
werden mit öffentlicher förderung das
ist der entscheidende punkt ganz
herzlichen dank für ihre zeit und ihre
expertise walter momper dankeschön vom
kleinen berlin im abgeordnetenhaus zum
großen berlin eben den reichstag ans set
dort und zur familie genau zurück ja
danke ihnen anhand in der tat wir sind
zurück im bundestag und werden die
gelegenheit mit dem bundeswahlleiter zu
sprechen danke dass sie zeit haben was
passiert jetzt rund eine stunde vor
schließung der wahllokale was machen sie
jetzt
haben jetzt voll stärke erreicht und
warten auf die dann ab 18 uhr
einlaufenden ergebnisse aus den
landeswahlleitung und insofern ist jetzt
alles ausstellung aber wir haben auch
viele fragen von bürgern die uns noch
etwas fragen und das muss alles
beantwortet werden das fragen sich die
bürger den meisten ja zb warum es zu
langen warteschlangen vor lokalen kommt
warum armin laschet wahl ist eine moment
ganz beliebte frage dass antworten wir
und ich glaube das ist auch gut so da
ist die bürger von der bundeswahlleiter
direkt eine antwort bekommen armin
laschet hat ja seinen stimmzettel falsch
gefaltet sodass man sehen konnte was er
gewählt hat was sagen sie dazu
wir sind alle nicht überrascht dass frau
laschet und hält dies so gewählt haben
die wahl vorschriften sind eindeutig man
soll das so ist wo gefaltet dass man es
nicht sieht eigentlich hätte der
wahlvorstand das sagen müssen so geht's
nicht bitte sie kriegen einen neuen
wahlzettel vernichten sie ihren aber ich
glaube das kann mal in der aufregung
wenn spitzenpolitiker kommen medien
kommt kann das alles passieren insofern
sollte man es nicht überbewerten auf
jeden fall die stimme ist gültig wie
sieht es denn mit der wahlbeteiligung
insgesamt ausfallen verglichen zur
letzten bundestagswahl für eine halbe
stunde haben wir ja was dazu gesagt die
ist ungefähr fünf prozent an der ohne
weniger dafür glaube ich haben wir aber
flächendeckend eine höhere
briefwahlbeteiligung und insofern gehe
ich aus dass wir die 72 prozent der
letzten bundestagswahl erreichen werden
ich denke sogar in manchen bereichen
wird es ein bisschen darüber legen was
verändert sich denn genau auch für ihre
arbeit angesichts dieses hohen briefwahl
anteils die logistik die alle treffen
müssen nicht nur die bundeswehr leitung
wie ich das machen ja im prinzip die
kreiswahl leitungen die müssen einfach
in der vorbereitung dass die
briefwahlunterlagen zum bürger kommen
und wieder zurück müssen vorbereitungen
getroffen werden und dann dauert es
natürlich briefwahlunterlagen
auszuzählen und vorzubereiten für die
auszeichnung das dauert etwas länger
also kann man wahrscheinlich davon
ausgehen dass wird ein bisschen später
in der nacht oder besser in den frühen
morgenstunden sein werden sie insgesamt
dafür dass man den zeitraum in dem brief
sei möglich ist verkürzt es gab ja auch
ein bisschen aufregung darüber dass in
einigen umfragen
menschen noch einmal befragt wurden die
ihre stimme per briefwahl schon
abgegeben haben ich habe das auch teil
des vg kassel zur kenntnis genommen das
steht einer bundeswahl leitung nicht zu
sagen wir müssen das so oder so in
gesetzen regeln das müssen die
parlamente entscheiden aber ich glaube
schon es gibt diskussionsrunde
erörterung bedarf aus der situation der
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat mal
gesagt die briefwahl ist sozusagen die
zweite säule aber die ohne wahl ist
eigentlich das leitbild und wenn wir am
ende jetzt 40 bis 50 prozent
briefwahl erreichen dann weiß ich nicht
mehr ob das mit dem leitbild noch
übereinstimmt aber das muss die politik
glaube ich entscheiden und nicht die
wahlleitung wir sind die schiedsrichter
der regeln die die parlamente machen
vielen dank herr thiel dann sind wir mal
weiter gespannt und damit erstmal zurück
zu meiner kollegin michaela kolster
vielen dank eva lindenau und auch an
georg thier vielen dank an den
bundeswahlleiter herr professor was
haben jetzt einiges zu besprechen wir
haben mecklenburg-vorpommern gehört wir
haben berlin gehört und auch den
bundeswahlleiter fangen wir mal bei
berlin in diesem fall an frau gefahr
liegt vorne in den umfragen das haben
wir gehört dringendstes problem in
berlin ist die wohnungsnot aber wenn man
sich frau griff er auch als kandidatin
anschaut dann wurde ja durchaus an der
einen oder anderen stelle gesagt dass es
schwierig ist mit ihr weil sie ja
nachgewiesen plagiate in ihren
abschlussarbeiten hatte
das scheint in berlin jetzt nicht so die
große rolle zu spielen wenn man das
vergleicht mit einem armin laschet der
an einer stelle falsch gelacht hat was
ein unglaubliches gewicht in seinen
wahlkampf eingebracht hatte kann man das
miteinander vergleichen man kann sie
insofern vergleichen weil man einfach
merkt wie unterschiedlich der fokus doch
ist den wir bei diesem wahljahr auf den
unterschied mal eben auch haben gerade
diesen beiden landtagswahlen in
mecklenburg vorpommern aber eben auch
hier in berlin den wird die
mobilisierung war sie abgenommen durch
die bundestagswahl aber mit eigenen
themen mit eigenen kandidatin kandidaten
mit all dem was sie mitbringen sichtbar
zu werden bei wählerinnen und wählern
wirklich sich abzuheben von dem was wir
als bundestrend haben das ist wahnsinnig
schwierig und insofern sind es sondere
landtagswahlen auch die wir heute
erleben die eigentlich so unter dem
radar durchlaufen und sehr sehr stark
unter bundespolitischen einflüssen zu
sehen sind schauen wir mal auf manuela
schwesig die mit sehr guten
umfrageergebnissen mecklenburg
vorpommern da steht die hat vor allen
dingen zu bonus nicht zuletzt durch die
korona pandemie die wir alle über jahre
erfahren haben das ist auch immer die
zeit der exekutive sollte man meinen
deshalb bei manuela schwesig sichtlich
gut geklappt aber einen amtsbonus für
armin laschet auch ministerpräsident in
nordrhein westfalen ist scheint es
zumindest in diesem wahlkampf für ihn
nicht gegeben zu haben wollen liegt das
nein ganz sicher nicht weiß was manuela
schwesig betrifft sehen wir eigentlich
ein sehr schönes fortsetzung dessen was
wir in diesem war ja auch auf andere in
anderen bundesländern schon gesehen
haben baden-württemberg rheinland- pfalz
sachsen-anhalt ja eigentlich drei völlig
unterschiedliche landtagswahlen aber
trotzdem immer mit einer bestätigung der
amtsinhaberin des amtsinhabers winfried
kretschmann malu dreyer reiner haseloff
das sind eben auch bekannte politiker
und politiker auf der ebene von landes
der landespolitik von bundesländern und
das ist überhaupt keine
selbstverständlichkeit also das ist das
große plus wenn man so will von diesen
beliebten ministerpräsidentin
ministerpräsidenten dass sie bekannt
sind an vielen stellen auch sehr sehr
geschätzt und angesehen sind und das ist
vielleicht auch der kleine unterschied
warum es für berlin doch ein bisschen
offener ist noch auf der ebene der
abgeordnetenhauswahl heißt es in
mecklenburg vorpommern der fall zu sein
scheint wo das rennen ja wirklich wenn
nicht ein eine sensation heute paar sind
und doch sehr klar zu sein scheint
schauen wir mal auf dem bundestag an
sich haben gerade vom bundeswahlleiter
gehört dass die wahlbeteiligung dass wir
eine höhere wahlbeteiligung erwartet als
das 2017 der fall war die wähler können
aber auch eins nämlich zum beispiel
durch stimmen splitting einen
unglaublich großen bundestag bestimmen
also es gibt stimmen die sagen dass es
über 800 abgeordnete sein werden die
hier in den bundestag einziehen sind da
fehler gemacht worden auch bei der
wahlrechtsreform
naja das ist sicherlich ein problem wir
haben eine normgröße für den bundestag
von 598 da sind wir jetzt schon sehr
weit von weg mit 709 und die zahlen
deuten eher auf größenordnung von 800
oder vielleicht sogar noch mehr hin das
zeigt ja alleine schon dass diese normen
größe eigentlich nicht mehr wirklich
eine relevanz hat davon redet kaum noch
jemand wie wir eigentlich diese sechs
politikwissenschaftler muss ich jetzt
noch mal fragen dass er inzwischen was
vielleicht noch mal erklären wie kommen
wir denn überhaupt auf 18 daher passiert
was passierte es ist sogar
vergleichsweise einfach in diesem wahl
der mann kann es am beispiel der csu
eigentlich sehr schön zeigen die csu
wird ungefähr einen stimmenanteil von
fünf prozent bundesweit wohlgemerkt
erzielen und wir haben ein verhältnis
wahlsystem das heißt der csu stehen fünf
prozent der sitze zu das sind bei 6 100
sitzen wären das ungefähr 30 sie wird
aber 45 oder über 40 wahlkreise gewinnen
davon kann man ausgehen und wenn ich ein
wahlkreis gewinne als partei dann steht
mir dieser sitz zu der ist dem
abgeordneten und damit auch der partei
gar an die erdbauarbeiten verhältniswahl
system haben muss ich dann den
bundestages solange vergrößern bis die
zahl der direkt gewonnenen mandate
sammeln für die csu sind es 40 5 prozent
der stimmen entspricht und so lande ich
dann bei größen von ungefähr 800 wird
sich im detail heute abend sicherlich in
die eine oder andere richtung noch
verschieben weil es eben von den
konkreten ergebnissen abhängen aber das
ist viel viel mehr als 600 werden das
kann man sagen und ich glaube man wird
auch jetzt schon sagen können ist liegt
dieses mal tatsächlich an der csu und
der konstellation dort dass sie mit den
zweitstimmen relativ schlecht
abschneiden wird aber trotzdem immer
noch sehr sehr viele wahlkreise gewinnen
wird
wir haben jetzt schon wie sie gesagt
haben man relativ großen bundestag
irgendwann wird der bundestag auch an
kapazitätsgrenzen stoßen auch was seine
arbeitsfähigkeit angeht sind es gibt nur
soviel ausschüsse die ausschüsse lassen
sich jetzt auch nicht beliebig
vergrößern oder nochmal neu verändern
oder einfach mal neu gründen kriegen die
abgeordneten dann überhaupt noch einen
platz in den ausschüssen kann man
überhaupt noch richtig arbeiten wie ich
ist das parlament mit so vielen
abgeordneten das ist genau der
zielkonflikt von dem wir hier sprechen
denn man konnte ja sagen jeder
abgeordnete der sorgt auch für mehr nähe
zu bürgerinnen und bürgern man könnte
den wir auch durchaus etwas positives
abgewinnen aber auf der anderen seite
steht eben die arbeitsfähigkeit gerade
auch eine sehr intensive
arbeitsatmosphäre in eigentlich sehr
kleinen ausschüssen nur auch die
ausschüsse werden größer werden und das
stellt einfach ein stück weit dann in
frage ob so ein miniatur plenum was wir
dann in den ausschüssen haben ob das
eigentlich wirklich noch intensiveres
arbeiten zulässt oder das nicht auch die
arbeitsweise von ausschüssen fundamental
ändern wird auch die reine logistik wir
sind eben eigentlich ein parlament was
auf 600 ausgelegt ist darf man gespannt
sein was hier in diesen räumlichkeiten
passiert also das ist schon ein
zielkonflikt performance sind ja
angedacht für die zukunft aber ich denke
wenn es wirklich ein sehr sehr großer
bundestag wird und wir auch vielleicht
andere mehrheiten im bundestag an dann
wird man sicherlich noch mal anschauen
dann wird es aber auch erst mal so sein
das kann man ja dann auch noch mehr
zurückbringen so weit erst mal vielen
dank und wir gehen noch mal zu meiner
kollegin eva lindenau die uns die
phönixstraße vorstellt
die wählenden ja das wort und wir bei
phoenix haben sechs von ihnen begleitet
stellvertretend für alle millionen der
für nix wahlstraße und das ist so bei
jedem der sechs steht eine andere partei
ganz hoch im kurs und bei uns kommen sie
zusammen zum austausch und zum digitalen
schlagabtausch
[Musik]
unser oma hat immer gesagt kompromiss
wir dem schwein wie kann man so etwas
erzählt emotionen ins spiel kommen jetzt
hat unser
verständnis ich bin ich vollkommen
verständlich sein indiskutables thema
waren viele an sich nur bei die ich so
nicht vermutet hätte ja der letzte
konservative am tisch für so habe ich
mich gefühlt ob er wirklich konservativ
ist wenn er fdp wird oder rechts ist
eine andere ich glaube die spd kommt
irgendwo um die 22 25 prozent
tatsächlich sind die sozialen medien
mittlerweile die orte in denen sich die
wahlen entscheiden werden
mein name ist dieser ich bin 31 mein
name ist besser wir sind sechs leute aus
essen werden alle anderen reporter und
diskutieren über alle möglichen themen
zu wollen oder instagram ja da gibt es
dann immer so einen kleinen
schlagabtausch untereinander in digital
weil wir ja jeder eine andere partei
wählen werden ob sind dann so
eine kleine bundestag debatte aber wir
sind heute bedeutet keine politiker ja
das ist ein wahnsinnig interessant das
projekt die phoenix wallstraße bloß für
instagram oder auch fürs fernsehen statt
und auch jetzt ist die phoenix
wahlstraße digital im stream aber auch
bei uns schalten wir jetzt mal zur zeche
zollverein nach essen da ist meine
kollegin jana becker mit den
teilnehmenden aus der wallstraße und
jana bei euch ist das jetzt so dass
jeder der teilnehmenden einer anderen
partei die daumen drückt wie ist es denn
dann so ein wahlabend gemeinsam zu
erleben
ja danke er war die stimmung hier ist
erwartungsvoll wie du gesagt hat es alle
bürger in der phönix wallstraße haben
unterschiedliche parteien gewählt
deswegen werden wir heute auch noch in
den austausch geben alle wählenden hier
haben
in den letzten drei monaten über unseren
phoenix instagram channel intensiv
diskutiert sich ausgetauscht den
wahlkampf beobachtet und da möchte ich
von dir gehören jetzt mal wissen du hast
die spd gewählt wie war das für dich
diese intensive auseinandersetzung mit
den themen das war für mich so dass ich
nicht mehr zum ersten mal man irgendwie
so wird sich die politik beschäftigt hat
jetzt ja in diesen 100 tagen
am anfang stand ja auch nicht ganz so
gut für die spd dass ich jetzt hier
unten doch zumindest wenn man den
prognosen wagen kam nach rechts oben
geändert hat und deswegen bin ich
gespannt was da noch passiert und wie
dann wirklich nach versuchen kurven zu
finden sind in der sz gleich zu dir du
hast die grünen gewählt er seit jetzt
natürlich ziemlich unterschiedliche
persönlichkeiten wie ja auch aufeinander
getroffen sind mit unterschiedlichen
haltungen und inhalten deswegen wie die
war der enge austausch für dich die drei
monate über
auch das war sehr interessant also ich
fand es sehr interessant dass man in
vielen dingen dann doch gar nicht so
weit auseinander lag und dass man da
sage ich mal schon auch gemeinsamkeiten
hatte also auch mit allen fand ich jetzt
das weiß nie so dass man wirklich das
ist so richtig knallte sondern dass man
so gemeinsam schon auch den anderen mit
verstanden hat ja selbst gesagt ich hab
nicht weit auseinander gelegen bei den
meisten themen bei vielen aber doch
andreas du fehlst mir da direkt ein
themen wie die klimadebatte oder auch
die ja die debatte um die um die
regenbogenfarben während der em du hast
jetzt die afg gewählt
wie also was war für dich denn die
hitzige diskussion kannst kannst du dich
da festlegen
es gab einige punkte in den
unterschiedlichen unterschiedlicher
meinung waren auch ziemlich konträr aber
ich denke werden das gut aus diskutiert
und sind am ende des tages auch
irgendwann zu einem konsens gekommen wo
man auch sagen kann dass man auch die
meinung des anderen akzeptieren kann und
wo man sie nicht teilt das halte ich für
sehr wichtig das fand ich sehr
interessant
die regenbogen geschichte natürlich ja
es gibt verschiedene sachen ich sehe ich
halt anders aber so ist nun mal halt im
leben
wie gesagt ziemlich viele
unterschiedliche positionen auch auch
gehabt auch wenn ihr euch menschlich wie
immer betont habe gut verstanden habe du
bist älteste der runde jetzt gewesen da
möchte ich einmal nach links rüber
schauen zu dir lister du bis 18 jahre
jungen konnte es jetzt auch das erste
mal an der bundestagswahl teilnehmen
da fällt mir jetzt auch direkt ein also
du hast die spd fdp gewählt das wollen
wir dazu sagen
da fällt dann natürlich jetzt direkt ein
16 jahre kanzlerin angela merkel wie ist
das jetzt für dich dass sich das dass
sich das ändert du kannst es ja gar
nicht anders
es ist sehr ungewohnt ich habe
eigentlich nur angela merkel als
kanzlerin erlebt und ich halte von ihr
persönlich sehr viel aber inhaltlich
sind wir doch relativ weit auseinander
und gerade bei union und spd ja auch so
nah beieinander sind bin ich gespannt
was es wird nur man muss auch ganz klar
sagen angela merkel hat als kanzlerin
sehr viel richtig gemacht auf einer
persönlichen ebene aber beispielsweise
sachen wie klimaschutz einfach
verschlafen und da hoffe ich jetzt auf
einen politikwechsel haben wir noch
alles verstehen die die cdu gewählt
haben aus zeitgründen gehen wir zurück
wollen aber jetzt einmal noch kurz sagen
dass wir gleich in dem
auf der phoenix youtube-seite im
livestream zu sehen sind zwei stunden
lang und weiter uns austauschen werden
und natürlich auch die ersten zahlen ja
aufnehmen werden aus berlin vorwärts
zurück in
vielen dank an jana becker und die
mitglieder der wallstraße ton probleme
die wir zeitweise hatten bitten wir zu
entschuldigen herr fast wären jetzt
gerade in der wallstraße
dort menschen erlebt die schon sehr früh
und sehr klar wussten was sie wählen
wollen man hört dabei immer wieder von
vielen unentschlossenen die quasi erst
in der wahlkabine sich entscheiden wen
sie letztendlich wählen wollen ist eine
längerfristige wähler bindungen nicht
mehr das was es heute noch so gibt sie
wird zumindest herausgefordert ich
glaube das prägt eigentlich diesen
wahlkampf wenn wir uns verschiedene
umfragezahlen anschauen dann haben wir
bei der direktwahlfrage am ende
eigentlich sehr deutlich gesehen dass
olaf scholz hier vorne lag wenn wir uns
die themen agenda angucken dann hat dort
sozusagen umwelt klimaschutz dominiert
aber es gibt eben noch viele menschen
die vielleicht in den letzten wahlen
immer angela merkel und die union
gewählt haben und diese menschen die
vielleicht scholz als kanzler
umweltpolitik als thema aber irgendwie
auch erfahrung mit der union haben genau
die mussten heute eine für sie
schwierige entscheidungen treffen wenn
sie konnten ja nur eine zweite stimme
vergeben das macht den heutigen wahltag
auch so spannend weil man nicht genau
weiß wie die eigentlich dann in dem
moment in dem sie da in der wahlkabine
standen was in dem moment der
ausschlaggebende faktor war kommt auf
den kanzler kommt auf das thema ankommt
auf die vergangenheit das was ich früher
gemacht habe die parteibindung
vielleicht an das ist wirklich das was
das so außergewöhnlich macht und das ist
auch der grund warum es durchaus noch
bewegung auf der zielgerade geben kann
wie muss man das bewerten ist das
ehrenzeichen für eine stabile demokratie
oder muss man sich eher sorgen machen
weil die wahlen oder wenn der wahltag
kommt es letztendlich von stimmungen
abhängt ja dass ich im wahlkampf fast
bewegt finde ich erstmal durchaus
positiv wäre langweilig wenn jede wahl
immer gleiche ausgehen würde dann könnte
man sagen was soll das überhaupt
wir wollen ja genau warnte wir wollen
reaktion auf entwicklung aber es bringt
natürlich herausforderung mit sich
einfach vor allem stabilität weil so
eine gewisse trägheit im system die
natürlich auch vorzüge hat wenn man über
stabilität kontinuität über viele jahre
und jahrzehnte nachdenkt die das mit
sich bringt das ist nicht mehr so wir
sehen unglaublicher ausschläger auch den
wirklich sehr sehr kurzer sicht das gilt
für die letzten wochen aber wenn man die
letzten zwei jahre sich in umfragen
anschaut was wir da an werten tiefsinn
höchstständen für die einzelnen parteien
gesehen haben da ist von trägheit und
und kontinuität wirklich wenig zu sehen
und das müssen wir alle gleich so ein
stück weit erst akzeptieren auch lernen
damit umzugehen dass die integrations
kraft von parteien und auch da sein kann
sehen wir durchaus auch an einigen
stellen mecklenburg vorpommern werden
uns heute sehen aber dass es eben keine
selbstverständlichkeit mehr ist und wenn
kurzfristige faktoren kandidierende
themen in eine andere richtung ziehen
als die parteibindung dann passiert eben
so was dass vieles möglich jetzt nun hat
man ja eigentlich in einer
legislaturperiode im bund vier jahre in
den ländern nächsten fünf jahre zeit
sich genau anzugucken wie die parteien
das machen und da sollte man ja
eigentlich meinen dass man nach vier
jahren auch ungefähr weiß in welche
richtung es geht also der wähler das
unbekannte wesen oder wie muss nur
zusammen fallen ja der wähler natürlich
auch ein wesen der vielleicht all diese
details die in einer vierjährigen
legislaturperiode verhandelt werden dann
doch nicht in jedem dieser details
nachverfolgt und das ist auch vollkommen
in ordnung deswegen haben wir eine
repräsentative demokratie weil eben
abgeordnete in diesen hallen des
bundestages eben vier jahre
stellvertretend für wählerinnen und
wähler agieren und dem wahlkampf ist
dann eher die herausforderung diese
details auch nochmal zuzuspitzen auch in
bestimmte richtungen visionen wird
manche sagen zu verdichten denn es ist
eine illusion zu glauben dass jetzt jede
wählerin und jeder wähler nicht meint es
gar nicht als vorwurf sondern ich glaube
dass eine realistische beschreibung
dessen was wir erleben all diese details
über ausstiegs jahre über exakte
steuersätze tetra nachvollzieht sondern
menschen wollen dinge auch
vertrauensvoll in die hände von parteien
und personen legen und darauf kommt es
dann auch im wahlkampf an genau diesen
eindruck diese kompetenz dieses
vertrauen jan sich auch ein stück zu
erarbeiten vielen dank für den moment
herr professor fast 16 jahre lang hat
sie die geschicke unseres landes gelenkt
jetzt geht die erste kanzlerin der
republik angela merkel war über jahre
eine konstante manches mal bejubelt
manches mal verflucht sie hat höhen und
tiefen erlebt viele krisen bewältigt
aber es ist auch einiges liegengeblieben
meine kollege matt des feldes mit einer
bilanz
angela merkel war immer die untypische
kanzlerin sie war die erste ostdeutsche
die erste frau im amt und sie hatte eine
ganz eigensinnigen sicht auf sich selbst
sieht sich nicht wirklich als teil des
establishments also das manchmal etwas
kuriose züge an dass einer ihrer frühen
vertrauten hat dann mal als ich vom
bundeskanzlerin war gesagt frau merkel
sie sind doch establishment er erzählte
mir dann dass sie eben ganz komisch
geguckt hatte angela merkel war immer
die frau mit der distanz distanz zu den
parteifreunden wie wir am anfang einfach
nicht ernst nehmen wollte sie hat
distanz zu ihrem amt distanz zu ihrem
volk vielleicht ergebnis einer jugend in
der ddr und einem spätstart in die
westdeutsche geprägte politik
da hatte ich glaube ich demokratie und
auch marktwirtschaft arbeitet wie ein
wissenschaftler das tut sie hat das eben
von optiker auf studiert merkels weg
durch die instanzen ist auch immer ein
weg durch krisen der sturz kohls und ihr
machtzuwachs gehen hand in hand damals
und sie erst das partei denkmal und dann
den eigenen parteichef zur seite merkel
und der kampf gegen die männer in der
union wird zu einem eigenen kapitel
angela merkel ist starke politische
führerin und das bedeutet dass auch
viele am ende nicht die politische
führung übernehmen weil sie sie hat und
mag sein dass sie nicht alle die
zugetraut habe aber sie hat sie das wenn
man sie unterschätzt hat man verloren
angela merkel gelingt in den krisen
immer der aufstieg in der finanz und
eurokrise wird sie zur mächtigsten und
meist kasten frau europas in der
flüchtlingskrise durch einen einzigen
satz zur hoffnungsträgerin
wir haben so vieles geschafft wir
schaffen das und die krise die ausgelöst
wird durch ein us wahl macht sie zur
führerin der westlichen welt
ich glaube sie hat keine hohe meinung
von dem volk das sie regiert
paradoxerweise war sie ja nur gerade
deshalb so erfolgreich weil die
deutschen sie gewählt haben als garanten
der stabilität und das sich nach
möglichkeit nichts ändern merkel ist
aber auch die kanzlerin der verpassten
chancen analytisch immer ganz weit vorn
politisch oft gestrandet
beim klima proklamiert sie lange zeit
ehrgeizige ziele umsetzen tut sie
deutlich zu wenig in der pandemie zeigt
sich dass so vieles bei musterschüler
deutschland nur fassade ist die
gesundheitsvorsorge hinkt hinterher die
digitalisierung der schulen wurde
schlicht nicht angepackt auch nichts tun
scheint teil des erfolges
dinge die sozusagen zu risikobehaftet
sind macht sie dann halt einfach nicht
sonst wäre sie wahrscheinlich nicht 16
jahre kanzlerin geblieben die ära merkel
geht zu ende und ihr erbe ist vielfach
ein trümmerhaufen die wunschnachfolgerin
gescheitert deren nachfolger steht
ebenfalls wochenlang hatte merkel sich
geweigert für armin laschet wahlkampf zu
machen symptomatisch für ihr verhältnis
zu ihrer eigenen cdu
bezeichnend war ja eher auftritt in der
sommerpressekonferenz wo sie zuerst
sagte die partei die mehr nahe steht und
dann fiel ihr irgendwie nach kurzem
nachdenken doch noch einen dass sie da
ja mitglied ist
wahlkampf für armin laschet im
strömenden regen von stralsund ihrem
alten wahlkreis ein letztes aufbäumen
ein letzter dienst an der partei
der bundesrat ist überhaupt läuft musst
du unbedingt bei tageslicht und
sonnenschein wieder hier
[Applaus]
16 jahre lang war angela merkel
kanzlerin dabei hat sie das land mehr
verändert als sie wohl selbst vermuten
würde
herr professor was reden wir nochmal
über angela merkel 16 jahre lang war sie
kanzlerin das hat es bisher noch nicht
gegeben dass ein kanzler oder kanzlerin
freiwillig die bühne verlassen hat wenn
man sich die geschichte der
bundesrepublik anschaut ist es das was
die nachfolge von angela merkel so
schwer macht oder ist es auch andere
faktoren die erzählen nein dadurch
bleibt natürlich eine riesige lücken
insbesondere auch weil es eben nicht wie
wir es häufig auf der ebene von
bundesländern sehen einen wechsel
gegeben hat in der hälfte der
legislaturperiode sondern sie ist ja und
sie wird auch noch ein paar wochen und
monate vielleicht die kanzlerin bleiben
und das war für annegret kramp
karrenbauer zuerst ja sehr schwierig als
die parteivorsitzende war profil zu
entwickeln und armin laschet hat sich
damit durchaus schwer getan sie ist auch
weiterhin eine sehr beliebte die
beliebteste politikerin in diesem land
das ist für laschet wirklich in
doppelter hinsicht schwierig gewesen
weil damit einfach implizit immer auch
ein referenzpunkt für ihn da war wie gut
eigentlich die menschen die aktuelle
kanzlerin bewerten und zugleich konnte
er sich in keiner weise von ihr
abgrenzen das kann man ihr vielleicht
durchaus vorwerfen dass sie diesen
übergang letztlich nicht organisiert hat
und dass das auch die probleme sind mit
denen die union mit der die union bis
heute eigentlich zu kämpfen hat wie
schwer ist es denn für die parteien nach
16 jahren regentschaft von angela merkel
quasi zum demokratischen normalfall
wieder wieder zurückzukehren denn der
normalfall ist ja durchaus auch der
regierungswechsel ja absolut und ich
meine man hat ja in der union zweikämpfe
um den parteivorsitz erlebte waren in
bester form und fassung könnte man sagen
denn es waren beide male sehr sehr
knappe entscheidung kramp karrenbauer
gegen märz laschet gegen märz da konnte
man sehen da stehen echte alternativen
zur verfügung beide male super knappe
entscheidungen aber man hat eben auch
gemerkt die union ist mit sich nicht im
reinen sie weiß eigentlich nicht wo sie
hin will sonst hätte es diese 50 50
entscheidung nicht gegeben und auch
söder gegen laschet war ein harter kampf
wo es auch wieder um so eine richtung
ging wo wollen wir eigentlich hin das
gab es in der zeit vorher nicht weil da
wollte man immer bei merkel stehen aber
für den nach merke zeit war man
eigentlich nicht wirklich gut
vorbereitet vielen dank für den moment
herr professor fas und ich gebe auch zu
meiner kollegin eva lindenau und zu
ihren gästen ja und ich freue mich jetzt
sehr weitere gäste hier bei uns im
bundestag am königswall zu begrüßen
gemeinsam wollen wir eruieren was die
besonderheiten dieser wahl waren und was
uns heute abend erwartet und bei uns
sind anhängig sie ist leiterin des
leipziger büros der zeit herzlich
willkommen und heribert prantl
langjähriger leiter der innenpolitik und
jetzt -kolumnist und autor bei der
süddeutschen zeitung
und christoph schwennicke ist bei uns
früher chefredakteur cicero jetzt
kolumnist bei der welt und bei t-online
und wir begrüßen den verleger und
publizisten wolfram weimer herzlich
willkommen ihn ein ja frau hennig bei
der wahl geht es ja um eine
weichenstellung für deutschland in den
kommenden jahren und es ist wirklich der
spannendste wahlausgang auch nach einem
wahlkampf der nicht zu den spannendsten
gehört hat ja was glauben sie wie
schätzen sie das ein wie blicken sie
zurück auf den wahlkampf und jetzt auf
den heutigen abend es war schon deswegen
eine besondere wahlkampf weil zum ersten
mal in der geschichte der bundesrepublik
seit 1949 nicht ein amtsinhaber
angetreten ist sondern lauter kandidaten
die noch nie kanzler waren so deswegen
war das besonders ich fand's über ich
fand es sehr spannend ich fand es
überhaupt nicht langweilig sondern wir
hatten so viele so viele debatten wie
noch nie angela merkel hat sich ja
relativ selten duellen gestellt oder so
dann gab es meistens ein fernsehduell
wir hatten alleine drei in diesem jahr
wir hatten unglaublich viele
unglaublich viele diskussionen und es
war am ende vielleicht ist es das was
sie von meinten es war diese erste
wahlkampfphase da hatte man den eindruck
es geht um banalitäten und um
kleinigkeiten es geht um den wahlkampf
von frau baerbock es geht darum wo armee
lasche wie gelacht hat für mich war das
gar nicht so überraschend weil die
öffentlichkeit journalisten wie bürger
eben wissen wollten sind die geeignet
die großen probleme die wir haben und
vor denen wir stehen die anzugehen so
deswegen war der wahlkampf sehr
personalisierte das war in der tat und
es ja viel im wahlkampf drüber
gesprochen worden reden wir zu wenig
über inhalte reden wir zu viel über
kleinigkeiten über personen wie schätzen
sie es ein woran lag es wenn sie der
auffassung sind dass wir zu wenig über
inhalte gesprochen haben also die
inhalte sind relativ kurz gekommen das
würde ich bestätigen das sehe ich so wir
müssen aber sehen war kämpfe dauerten
früher auch wesentlich länger und seit
einigen jahren reduziert sich das auf 68
wochen letzten endes vielleicht sogar
noch kürzer dann am ende und da ist
natürlich der der lichtkegel die kamera
auf die drei kandidaten oder die
kandidatin und die zwei anderen
kandidaten gerichtet und dann wird alles
sehr stark personalisierte und dann
kommt eben ein törichtes lachen oder
einen zusammengeklebtes buch
ganz ganz hoch auf die agenda und die
themen tun es nicht aber wir müssen uns
auch ehrlich machen auch als medien
finde ich also wir sagen immer die
themen kommen zu kurz wir hätten alle
möglichkeit die themen groß zu spielen
aber am ende beschäftigen wir uns
natürlich auch lustvoll mit der frage
wer von den dreien ist denn jetzt der
geeignete oder die geeignetste jetzt ist
ja so diese sechs bis acht wochen der
ständige gerade ansprach das sind ja die
zeit also die sechs wochen in der auch
briefwahl schon stattfindet sehen sie da
ein problem ich habe es ja eben auch
schon beim bundeswahlleiter thematisiert
dass menschen schon gewählt haben und
manche punkte die trainer noch gar nicht
stattgefunden haben naja ich bin nicht
donald trump um jetzt die briefwahl
schlechtzureden und jetzt erstmal
wichtiger ist die wahlbeteiligung ist
wirklich hoch und wir haben ja eine
marke
an der wir uns ausrichten können die
berühmten willy brandt war 1972 eine
wahlbeteiligung von 91,1 prozent
das ist für mich immer noch die marke
die zu erreichen ist und
demokratie ist mit reden und mit wählen
erst einmal und da freue ich mich über
eine hohe wahlbeteiligung ob die mit
briefwahl oder an der urne zustande
kommt ist mir erst mal gleich aber es
verändert natürlich den wahlkampf wenn
die stimmabgabe über eine ganze zeit
sich hin streckt ich sage ganz gern weil
tage sind die geburtstage der demokratie
das schönste an geburtstage sind die
überraschungen die werden wir vielleicht
heute noch erleben aber es sind ja dann
dadurch die briefwahl eigentlich keine
geburtstage sondern richtige wochen und
das verändert auch den wahlkampf das
wird den wahlkampf nach den ergebnissen
die wir heute hören werden eine sehr
sehr hohe privatanteil wird das den
wahlkampf künftig verändern wird
vielleicht sehr viel früher beginnen als
jetzt die kollegen haben zu recht gesagt
sechs wochen dabei man so den sechs
wochen eigentlichen wahlkampf oder acht
wochen eigentlichen wahlkampf den
vorwahlkampf in der cdu/csu hinzurechnen
muss der hatte ja schon ganz klar
wahlkampf charakter und wenn wir heute
haben möglicherweise sagen werden
laschet hat schlecht abgeschnitten
werden wir diese vorwahl mit einbeziehen
müssen sich ja mal gespannt was jetzt
passiert heute abend 1 zeichnet sich ab
zumindest wenn man jetzt die letzten
umfragen beobachtet hat dass es die
ihrer merkel möglicherweise so endet wie
sie begonnen hat wirklich mit einem
kopf-an-kopf-rennen zwischen spd und cdu
für die union werden dass hätten jedem
fall wirklich herbe verluste glauben sie
dass die union unterschätzt hat dass man
nach den ihrer merkel nicht einfach auf
so ein weiter so setzen kann nein das
glaube ich dich die union ringt ja seit
zwei jahren mit der nachfolge der wir
erinnern uns an annegret kramp
karrenbauer und dann die gemengelagen
die abhandlung habe geschrieben hat ich
bin übrigens auch bei ihm wenn er sagt
es ist eine gute nachricht dass werden
die 80 prozent oder vielleicht sogar
darüber wahlbeteiligung kommen es gibt
ein zweiter eine zweite gute in tendenz
nämlich soweit und wir sind ja immer
selbstfindungs momente einer republik
diesmal hat sich die republik mehr in
der mitte gesucht und gefunden die
umfragen sagen uns dass wir sowohl bei
afg als auch bei linkspartei deutliche
rückgänge wahrscheinlich erleben werden
die haben beim letzten mal ja fast 22
prozent der stimmen gast das heißt fast
jeder also führte fünfte deutsche hat
eine extremistische partei gewählt wenn
wir das jetzt sehen was uns die umfragen
sagen dann kommen die vielleicht
zusammen noch auf 15 das ist nur noch
jeder siebte das heißt die haben ein
drittel ihrer wählerschaft verloren das
ist an so einem abend die eine gute
nachricht ist die wahlbeteiligung steigt
die andere ist die extremistischen
parteien verlieren insofern halte ich
das für eine positive entwicklung ja ich
würde bei der briefwahl trotzdem ein
zwei kritikpunkte anbringen wollen
natürlich ist es grundsätzlich gut
niedrigschwellig jedem die möglichkeit
zu geben zu wählen und da ist ja alles
jedes mittel gut und richtig so lange es
denn mit rechten dingen zugeht aber ich
finde schon dass wir zwei
geschwindigkeiten haben die nicht
zueinander passen also du machst auf der
einen seite die briefwahl
möglichkeit sechs wochen vor der wahl
auf wir haben zugleich inzwischen bei
kämpfen die sich eigentlich erst dann
nachvollziehen das heißt es können schon
ganz viele große stapel an das
briefwahlunterlagen irgendwo verstauben
während eigentlich sich dieser das
schaulaufen dieser in dem fall jetzt
drei personen die sich ums kanzleramt
bewerben erst stattfindet und wir haben
amplituden gehabt in dieser zeit nur mal
also auf und ab im mai haben die grünen
die cdu überholen ja jetzt sieht es
wieder ganz anders aus also ich finde
diese zwei geschwindigkeiten passen
nicht so richtig zusammen ich persönlich
hätte nichts gegen entschleunigung ich
hätte auch nichts dagegen gegen ein
moratorium von umfragen sagen wir vier
wochen vor weil auch da sehr viel
einfluss genommen wird weil das narrativ
natürlich immer verstärkt wird
da wären wir nicht hinkommen deswegen
finde ich es sinnvoller heribert prantl
hat zu recht gesagt dass der wahltag war
eigentlich mal der geburtstag der
demokratie ich finde dass das solid wird
nicht gut und idealerweise hätte man
doch digitale briefwahl möglichkeiten
die dann aber auch näher an dem wahltag
liegen könnten weil dann ist nicht so
erheblich dass ich vorher noch das ist
so schädlich wenn wir verschiedene
wahl.de wahlzeit punkte haben wir
erleben ja ein wahlkampfes ohnehin
christoph schwennicke hat beschrieben
ein auf und ab es ist eine fahrt mit der
geisterbahn
man weiß nicht was hinter der nächsten
kurve wartet dann sagen wenn es klappt
darauf dass sie gleich mal aus wie söder
das sieht einmal aus wie der
kanzlerkandidat der cdu und noch was
besonderes
wir erleben zum ersten mal einen
pandemie wahlkampf unter ganz ganz
besonderen bedingungen
und das war überhaupt nicht kalkulierbar
keiner der kandidaten wusste wie schauen
die einschlägigen zahlen aus wie
entwickelt sich diese pandemie all das
hat die großen einfluss auf die wahlen
und es gibt halt verschiedene zeitpunkt
jetzt zu sagen es muss das ergebnis
eines einzigen eines ganz bestimmten
tages das ergebnis der wahl prägen ich
weiß nicht ob das demokratischer ist
weil es dann wenn sich sogar einige
wochen stellte ganz gern noch mal auf
diese unterschiedlichen
geschwindigkeiten die sie angesprochen
haben eingehende vor einigen auch mit
blick auf den einfluss die sozialen
medien ja in diesem wahlkampf hatten so
stark wie ja auch noch bei keinem
anderen wahlkampf wie schätzen sie das
ein frau hennig ist das was was ohnehin
jeglichen versuch von entschleunigung im
keim ersticken würde also
entschleunigung kann ich mir in
anbetracht der tatsache dass sich alles
immer nur beschleunigt auch nicht so
richtig vorstellen die sozialen medien
sind ein ganz interessanter punkt weil
ich den eindruck habe dass die parteien
da noch unterschiedlich professionell
unterwegs sind also heutzutage weiß
jeder dass wenn man beispielsweise eine
junge zielgruppe erreichen will dann
muss man geld investieren um wahlkampf
in den sozialen medien zu machen ich
nehme aber war dass es eine partei gibt
die darin schon sehr gut ist das ist die
ft der gelingt es sehr gut der junge
leute zu erreichen und das sehen wir
dann auch in den umfragewerten wir sehen
dass die fdp bei den ältesten die
stärkste kraft ist sondern bei den
jüngeren gruppen relativ stark ist und
das hat auch was damit zu tun dass die
professionell mit mit facebook umgehen
mit tik tok umgehen das ist etwas wo
andere parteien noch sehr jungfräulich
unterwegs sind vielleicht war es ja für
einige parteien auch nachteil dass die
kandidaten einfach so spät fest standen
das war natürlich bei der spd nicht so
aber bei den anderen war so und auch das
ist natürlich etwas was eine strategie
beeinflusst wie schätzen sie den
einfluss ein dass in diesem jahr waren
die wähler auch so wählerisch wie noch
nie wir haben ja bewegungen wir sehen
ihn um fragen wie wir das noch nie
erlebt haben im frühjahr war annalena
baerbock schon die gefühlte kanzlerin
und im frühsommer war armin laschet der
gefühlte kann so wieder diskutiert nur
darum welche koalition wird das wohl
werden im august war es mit olaf scholz
das schöne an dieser wahl ist dass wir
alle immer überrascht wurden von unseren
eigenen fantasien und dass die wähler
dieses feste demokratie wirklich zu
einem fest gemacht haben und uns immer
wieder überrascht haben das kann heute
abend ja auch noch die überraschung
wollen wir mal gerade zur cdu einmal
schalten ins konrad adenauer haus zu
meinem kollegen gerd joachim von fallois
joachim bei euch könnte in der tat
entweder wahlverluste mutmaßlich
erwartet werden oder auch jubel
ausbrechen wie es denn jetzt gerade die
stimmung
ja mit wahlverlusten ist hier natürlich
zu rechnen
32,9 prozent das war so viel beim
letzten mal das wird man dieses mal
sicherlich nicht bekommen für die cdu
geht es darum die nase vorne zu halten
ich hätte an dieser stelle gerne ein
interview mit einem stellvertretenden
parteivorsitzenden hier gehabt aber es
gibt ein sprechverbot seit 17 uhr sitzt
das präsidium zusammen auch vorher waren
keine gespräche möglich um so vor bin
ich dass thomas heilmann zu uns gekommen
ist der ehemalige justizsenator hier in
berlin seit vier jahren
bundestagsabgeordneter für den wahlkreis
stets direkt gewählt schön dass sie da
sind ich habe es gesagt es wird sie auf
jeden fall verluste geben worauf ist das
zurückzuführen nur darauf dass viele
menschen angela merkel gewählt haben und
gar nicht die cdu ist das nicht auch ein
problem für jeden kandidaten der hier
heute angetreten wäre ja das wäre sicher
für jeden kandidaten schwierig gewesen
das unter langen phase
auch nach so einer langen phase im
kanzleramt bei der die cdu ja auch für
vieles verantwortlich gemacht wird was
sie hätte gerne selber getan hätte aber
wir keine mehrheiten hatten aber das
gehört nun mal zum geschäft dazu
deswegen
beklagen geht nicht also spielen wir ja
noch bis 18 uhr es ist noch nichts hören
sie im bereich umwelt ja zum team von
laschet deswegen die frage vielleicht
ungerecht aber viele in der cdu sagen
das ist der falsche kandidat wobei mir
aufgefallen ist dass bei dem dreikampf
um die cdu spitze und auch hinterher bei
dem zweikampf mit herrn söder die die
verloren haben sich dummerweise nicht
hinter ihrem kandidaten versammelt haben
will sagen viele in der cdu kämpfen gar
nicht so wie sie es eigentlich müssten
ja das kann ich für den schluss nicht
sagen wir haben ja so wie die umfragen
der letzten tage war auch noch etwas
aufgeholt
und natürlich ist es so wenn das nicht
so ausgehen wie wir uns das wünschen
dann ist das ein verlustes der gesamten
mannschaft zu der ich auch gehöre und
ich finde es ein bisschen früh jetzt
schon so analysiert also die wahllokale
sind geschlossen das finde ich ist jetzt
für seine berichterstattung was waren
das alles falsch ein bisschen früher war
laschet der falsche kandidat ich sag nur
lachen die modernen medien haben es
immer wieder gegeben heute die falsche
stimmabgabe in anführungsstrichen also
das lachen hat er ja selber als fehler
bezeichnet
ich finde das nicht gerecht dass einem
so eine minute irgendwie darüber
entscheidet wie ein erfolgreicher
ministerpräsident beurteilt wird aber so
ist das leben findet beklagen gilt nicht
sondern wir müssen
das gemeinsam jetzt mal sehen wie weit
wir kommen wird ja wohl eher ein kopf an
kopf rennen wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe von den demoskopen in
den letzten tagen
und das macht ja politisch dann auch ein
riesenunterschied ob es eine
rot-rot-grüne mehr gibt oder ob wir das
verhindern können ob die cdu vorne liegt
oder nicht das wird ein riesen
unterschied machen oder wenn wir länger
warten müssen heute bis zur ergebnisse
haben abgeordnetenhauswahl ist heute
auch in mecklenburg vorpommern wird
gewählt da hat die cdu beide male wohl
nichts mit dem ausgang des rennens zu
tun warum nicht was muss die cdu ändern
wir sagen der politik immer das große
wasser nimmt das kleine wasser mit und
natürlich ist ins bundespolitische wurde
mecklenburg wie in berlin der wind sehr
von vorne gegen geblasen gewesen und wie
das jetzt in berlin ausgeht da habe ich
mir nicht so sicher
und ob rot rot grün fortgesetzt wird was
die mehrheit der berliner nicht wollen
ist auch fraglich also sofort ist auch
da noch gar nicht entschieden
vielen dank thomas heilmann war das
meine damen und herren und es geht
weiter im willy brandt haus mit meinem
kollegen erhard scherfer
auch wie sagt man so schön mit händen
greifbar das sieht man unter anderem
auch daran dass wir eine verabredung
hatten mit einer stellvertretenden
parteivorsitzenden aber die gremien der
spd tagen schon in diesen minuten vorhin
hat das präsidium zusammengesetzten
gesessen jetzt schließt sich eine
sitzung eine besprechung des
parteivorstands 1 aber wir haben
nichtsdestotrotz eine hochinteressante
und kluge gesprächspartnerin gefunden
hier im atrium des willy-brandt-hauses
jansen käsetheke ist bei uns
bundestagsabgeordnete und hier aus
berlin
unsere moderatorin hat mich von einer
guten stunde gefragt wie euphorisiert
die spd in diesen tagen ist ich habe das
nach bestem wissen und gewissen
beantwortet wie ist es denn tatsächlich
jetzt geben sie uns mal ein bisschen was
aus dem aus dem inneren blick raus ja
total das ist sehr aufregend und sehr
sehr spannend bekennen ja die
umfrageergebnisse in den letzten wochen
das hat uns natürlich nicht davon
abgehalten oder in sicherheit gewogen
wir haben bis zu diesem tag bis an
diesem tag sind wir hingefiebert
sozusagen gekämpft unsere pläne für die
zukunft den bürgerinnen und bürger
vorgestellt und ich hoffe die
bürgerinnen und bürger schenken uns ihr
vertrauen der ja gesehen weiter arbeiten
eine gewisse nachdenklichkeit auch eine
gewisse demut und trotzdem aber auch ein
bisschen genugtuung dass die zahlen
endlich mal aus spd-sicht das gespiegelt
haben wir die spd ihre arbeit ja
eigentlich auch sieht im bundestag vor
allem absolut wir haben eine gute arbeit
gemacht in den letzten vier jahren
insbesondere in der pandemie haben wir
sozialdemokratische punkte programmatik
durchgesetzt für die menschen in diesem
land und unsere pläne für die zukunft
ist auch für die bevölkerung für das
gemeinwesen für das gemeinwohl und ich
hoffe die wählerinnen und wähler werden
dass auch wertschätzen und das wird sich
auch in den ergebnissen niederschlagen
was sind denn ihre erwartungen an das
ergebnis heute abend es wird ein kopf an
kopf rennen denke ich wir haben eine
super aufholjagd hingelegt wir haben
überzeugt mit unserem zukunftsprogramm
es gibt drängende herausforderung die
bezahlbare mieten sichere renten
digitalisierung und eine
sozial-ökologische klimapolitik für die
wir stehen und das haben wir versucht
den bürgern nahe zu bringen jetzt ist
das nicht der erste bundestagswahlkampf
gewesen gehen sie mitgemacht haben wenn
sie mal vergleichen mit diesen hier in
diesem jahr mit dem vor vier jahren es
hat viel kritik an diesem wahlkampf
gegeben es sei wenig um inhalte gegangen
sondern es wurden dann vermeintliche
kleinigkeiten nach vorne gespielt auch
persönliche fehler die gemacht worden
sind was ist ihr eindruck von diesen
vergangenen zwei drei monaten wahlkampf
das kann ich für die union bestätigen da
haben sie recht die union hat an
angstkampagne angst wahlkampf gemacht
eine rote socken kampagne die völlig
nach hinten losgegangen ist aus meiner
sicht die union hat nicht auf inhalte
gesetzt und wenden sich wenn man sich
das wahlprogramm der union anschaut
sieht man auch da gibt es keinen plan
für die zukunft und das war auf die
schwierigkeit in den letzten vergangenen
jahren die als spd haben viele gute
sachen durchgesetzt gegen großen
widerstand und wir hoffen dass wir
andere politische mehrheiten in diesem
land haben er hat hier noch mal ein
bisschen wahlkampf untergehe mogelt hier
in diesem gespräch ist olaf scholz hat
mir eigentlich bis heute ist vermieden
koalitionsaussagen zu machen die über
einen über die bereitschaft mit den
grünen zusammenzuarbeiten hinaus
gegangen sind hätten sie sich so gerne
parteilinken an hätten sie sich daher
klarere aussagen oder deutlichere
aussagen gewünscht auch in richtung
eines saskia esken mal genannt hat
progressiven bündnis ist also eins mit
den linken natürlich ist ein
progressives bündnis besser für ein land
für deutschland aber es ist taktisch
strategisch sehr unklug solche aussagen
vor der wahl zu treffen
wir reden natürlich mit allen
demokratischen parteien und das bleibt
auch so wirkt schauen mal wie das
wahlergebnis ist und dann werden auch
die gespräche geführt also weil die
zurückhaltung von urlaub schon so
richtig aus ihrer sicht
war das hier im atrium des willy brandt
hauses wo übrigens deswegen werden wir
wahrscheinlich um kurz nach 18 uhr keine
jubelbilder oder auch keine depressiven
bieten können überwiegend medien
versammelt sind hier die anhänger und
parteimitglieder sind draußen in kleinen
zelten auf kleineren kurzen bierbänken
hier jenseits der stresemannstraße so
viel im moment aus dem willy-brandt-haus
von der spd zurück zu fallen genau in
unserem wahlstudio die haar danke er hat
also wir richten uns hier auch gemeinsam
auf einen möglich hoch spannenden
wahlabend ein mit einem kopf an kopf
rennen inwiefern wird das denn die
politische lage in deutschland verändern
dass das ja wirklich so ist dass man von
volkspartei wenn sich das so bestätigt
gar nicht mehr unbedingt so sprechen
kann also ich bin nicht bei denen die
volkspartei die volksparteien jetzt
schon
beerdigen ich glaube dass die auch
wieder stark werden können vielleicht
sehen wir ja heute sogar in mecklenburg
vorpommern beispielsweise das man als
volkspartei auch durchaus noch
volkspartei artige wahlergebnisse
zustande bringen kann aber im bund ja da
werden wir jetzt das nicht so erleben
das stimmt wir werden uns also zum
ersten mal auf eine wahrscheinlich
dreier-koalition einstellen müssen wobei
wenn man es ganz genau nimmt ist auch
eine große koalition eine
dreier-koalition weil die cdu und csu am
ende manchmal auch zwei sind und nicht 1
vielleicht vielleicht habe ich einfach
von dem begriff volkspartei ganz anders
an schienen jetzt ganz unabhängig von
irgendwelchen prozent seien volkspartei
ist ein begriff aus der ich sage mal so
einfach und aus der vw käfer zeit die
frühe bundesrepublik mit ganz bestimmten
gefestigten schichten mit ganz
bestimmten loyalitäten spd ihr
gewerkschaften cdu/csu die kirchen diese
loyalitäten diese alten loyalitäten sind
vorbei ich glaube wir sollten uns daran
gewöhnen auch wenn die bisherigen
volksparteien den begriff gerne
gebrauchen weil sie nobilitiert aber ich
denke auch eine partei wie die grünen
sind eine volkspartei ich denke wir
haben eine entwicklung von den
dominierenden parteien der 50er 60er und
70er jahre hin zu großen mittelparteien
wenn du ja herrn auch die wahlergebnisse
auf der basis der bisherigen umfragen
betrachten werden wird sich zeigen da
liegen parteien zwischen 15 und 25
prozent aber ich frage zielt auf die
stabilität der republik abwehr nach
vorne kam ich glaube wir kriegen in
stabilere fällt nicht so kann man sagen
die alten waren so stabil dass sie
langweilig waren und nichts mehr
passierte in der republik aber eine
dreier konstellation ist per se erst mal
schwieriger das heißt ein kanzler egal
ob da nun laschet oder scholz heißt er
hat es machtpolitisch schwieriger dann
wird er gewählt wahrscheinlich von drei
vierteln der deutschen die gewählt haben
nicht hat es auch so doch noch gegeben
dann hat egal ob laschet oder scholz es
wird jeweils die eigene partei auch
wieder worte so groß wie in anderen
konstellationen selten also scholz hat
natürlich mit seiner truppe kühnert
borjans ist
ab 18 uhr sofort auf einmal wieder eine
neue konstellation mit ihr umgehen muss
bei laschet genau das gleiche mit blick
auf münchen das heißt der neue kanzler
wird auf jeden fall eine schwächere
figur als wir das in den letzten jahren
von angela merkel und herr frau hin ich
das glauben sie wie schätzen sie das ein
wird es mit einer dreier-koalition
schwieriger oder ist es vielleicht weil
es einfach eine neue koalition ja dann
in jedem fall wäre auch ein aufbruch ich
glaube es ist schon schwieriger
andererseits wenn wir in die
bundesländer gucken dann sehen wir dort
lauter länder die längst von drei
parteien regiert werden und es
funktioniert auch teilweise auch mit
einer stimme mehrheit über fünf jahre
hinweg also das ist nichts unmöglich ist
auch die koalitionsverhandlungen vor
vier jahren mit drei partnern
beziehungsweise 4 und wenn man die csu
zählt liefen ja ganz gut bis zu dem
moment als die fdp verkündet hat dass
sie aus nebulösen kunden jetzt doch
nicht in einer jamaika koalition
mitregieren möchte das heißt natürlich
ist das schwieriger aber so sind die
bedingungen eben jetzt auch noch das
entschuldigung das dreier koalition per
se instabiler ist wir haben regierungen
gehabt
nehmen sie die großen konflikte zwischen
helmut kohl und franz josef strauß und
in der gleichen partei die konflikte
tobten ich glaube die kunst des
regierens wird sich darin zeigen mit
dreier koalitionen zurecht zu kommen und
wir dürfen nicht vergessen wir hatten in
deutschland und die steht auch nicht an
die minderheitenregierung andere länder
haben mit minderheitenregierung durchaus
passabel und effektiv regiert was wir
erleben werden ist eine neue
konstellation und wir haben immer gesagt
die alten konstellationen sind irgendwie
überkommen und langweilig aber es gibt
was neues es gibt schon es gibt schon
einen wie soll ich sagen eine
sollbruchstelle bei den zwei letztlich
zwei dreier konstellationen auf dieses
mutmaßlich auf eine davon heraus also
jamaika oder oder die ampel deutschland
koalition können wir glaube ich ein
stück weit hinten anstellen du hast in
wahrheit hier jeweils eine zweier
konstellation mit einem stütz rädchen
also natürlich ist eine ampel rot grün
mit stützrädern fdp jedenfalls aus sicht
von rot und grün und natürlich ist
jamaika
koalition aus schwarz und gelb mit
stützengrün und das wird in beiden
fällen glaube ich sehr interessant
werden zu sehen es hat einmal ja schon
einer nämlich christian lindner gesagt
dann reagiere ich lieber nicht mit wenn
ich den eindruck habe hier das städtchen
zu sein das wird sehr sehr interessant
sein zu sehen ob das dann tatsächlich
wenn das wenn sich alle drei da
hinreichend wiederfinden zum modewort es
belegt dann kann es stabil sein wenn
aber tatsächlich ist eigentlich eine
zweierkoalition mit hilfsmotor ist dann
dann wird es schwierig glauben sie denn
dass christian lindner hat noch mal sein
das gericht kann ja nicht er muss auf
jeden fall wenn die möglichkeit da ist
muss er mit regierung werden den deckel
so gerade einmal zum längerer
installationen die angesprochen sind und
die die wahrscheinlichen sind
tatsächlich so etwas wie eine liberale
konkurrenz erleben beide parteien grün
und gelb sind ja im prinzip liberale
parteien in verschiedenen ausstattungen
grün finde ich jetzt nicht so
die liberale kraft in dem lande und wer
präsentiert sich wie bei einer starken
kraft und zwei mittleren kräften werden
sich die mittleren jeweils konkurrieren
und werden sich aneinander reiben das
wird mit den koalitionsverhandlungen
beginnen und wird in der regierungszeit
weitergehen der kann die
koalitionsverhandlungen wie das glauben
sie wenn jetzt die beiden union und spd
so nahe beieinander liegen wie wird das
ablaufen werden beide möglicherweise
reklamieren möglich mit den san siro
sinnlose mikado spiel der macht politik
da geht es ja auch darum wenn die jetzt
relativ nahe beieinander liegen die
beiden großen wer von den kleinen bewegt
sich als erster der hat dann möglich
aber ist auch schon verloren und jetzt
geht es auch um diplomatische geschick
wer zieht wien auf welcher seite wir
wissen von den grünen dass das fahrwerk
lage eigentlich lieber jamaika will das
baerbock lager will will lieber die
ampel ich das schöne ist es wird
wahrscheinlich nach 18 uhr genauso
spannend wie vor 18 uhr
das ist richtig und wir werden denke ich
gespräche haben die nicht nacheinander
auf ablaufen es werden parallel
gespräche stattfinden und da wird die
große kunst das ist eine mediation die
hier stattfindet aber wie läuft das ab
vorher nicht was glauben sie ich wollte
gerade noch sagen bedingungen für
gespräche sind natürlich dass man
überhaupt noch ein parteichef hat der
sich als solcher auch begreifen kann das
ist in der cdu müssen wir erstmal sehen
ob das wirklich so kommt also wenn armin
laschet ein sehr schwaches ergebnis
haben wird dann bin ich mir nicht sicher
ob er innerhalb der parteien noch eine
solche macht
bei der spd ist scholz nicht parteichef
abs ein bisschen in einer komfortableren
lage weil wenn die wahlergebnisse so
sein werden wie die umfragen zuletzt
dann wird es ein solcher erfolg sein der
ja auch auf ihn persönlich zurückgeht
das war eine scholz kampagne es war
keine spd kampagne dass er in einer
komfortableren lage ist als laschet das
ist ja wirklich das besondere an den
wahlkampf ich glaube ich habe so was nie
erlebt in meiner journalistischen zeit
eine solche wir präsentieren gern dann
könnte man schreibt müsste größte
auferstehung seit lazarus und was damit
der spd passiert ist die spd war kaputt
wir haben sie auch so beschrieben und
kein mensch hat den pfifferling auf die
spd gerettet und dann kamen plötzlich
dieser schutz wahlkampf den wir alle am
anfang noch belächelt haben und dann
steigt dieser schatz auf und zieht die
spd hinter sich her in einer weise die
kaum einer für möglich gehalten hätte
und
nun in der scholz aufstieg oder ein
wahlsieg der spd es war natürlich eine
implosion der beiden anderen wir haben
ja nicht die stimmung wie 98 am ende der
ära kohl wirklich die spd und ein
kandidat schröder wirklich mobilisiert
damit leute begeistert waren von einer
neuen rot grünen idee die spd regiert
von den letzten 25 jahren 21 jahre und
sogar länger als die union also diese
stimmung ist nicht da das ist eine
relative den die anderen haben so
michaela gemacht dass auf einmal die spd
mit ihren kleineren und größeren sonne
schieben
das muss glaube ich schon konzipiert
haben ja der spd ist besser als die der
der union so weit kann man sich
natürlich schon ländlichen sodass und
dann kamen aber natürlich diese zwei
stolperer von frau bär bock und von
herrn asche dazu und dann bist du halt
relativ gesehen form also olaf scholz
wurde zum baum unter büschen weil die
beiden anderen gewaltige fehler gemacht
haben und dann erstrahlte er plötzlich
in neuer in neuem licht und das
zusammengenommen also ein stringenter
wahlkampf und letztlich die fortüne dass
die anderen fehler gemacht haben die er
nicht macht er ist extrem erfahren damit
geht halt leider auch eine gewisse
langeweile einher weil weil er eben so
ist wie er ist aber fehler macht solche
fehler macht er eben die anderen beiden
liegen jedoch
sowohl er immer noch so agiert
interessant ich würde ganz gerne noch
mal kurz auf die grünen blicken wo ja
vor allen dingen auch diese fehler
passiert sind wie muss man sich das
wirklich vorstellen dass die partei
wirklich ganz anders in diesem wahlkampf
gestartet ist und jetzt überlegen muss
sind sie auf platz drei wie stark werden
sie bei den sondierungen mitsprechen
können und ihre ziele durchsetzen können
waren es die fehler war es der
geschickte wahlkampf von scholz auch da
wieder die frage also das was sich die
grünen vorgenommen haben war ja ohnehin
enorm sie wollten gerne den kanzler oder
die kanzlerin stellen und das haben sie
noch nie in der bundesrepublik
deutschland sie waren zwar in den
umfragen über jahre hinweg immer ganz
gut bei 20 prozent positioniert also
jeder fünfte konnte sich vorstellen
diese partei zu wählen nicht nur in
umfragen sondern bei der europawahl vor
zwei jahren wurden sie ja auch von 20
prozent der deutschen gewählt hier in
deutschland aber
es ist dann eben doch noch einmal etwas
anderes eine bundestagswahl zu gewinnen
da muss alles stimmen und b braucht man
auch genug zeit politik ist handwerk
also auch kampagne machen ins handwerk
um so eine kampagne vorzubereiten und da
haben die grünen den gleichen fehler
gemacht wie die cdu sie haben monatelang
gewartet bevor sie ihren
kanzlerkandidaten ihre kanzlerkandidaten
ausgerufen haben und dann war es halt
auch schon ganz schön spät also wenn man
sich im april dafür entscheidet
hat man nicht mehr genug zeit um zu
gucken stimmt eigentlich die message mit
der kandidaten über ein wie gehen wir in
diesem wahlkampf welche themen lassen
wir weg olaf scholz zum beispiel der
viele themen einfach weggelassen weil er
wusste es passt nicht in meine kampagne
all diese gedanken konnten sich die
grünen gar nicht mehr machen es war am
ende
eine gewisse unprofessionalität nicht
nur von der kandidatin selbst sondern
von der gesamten partei
die entscheidende frage und das ist ja
auch das ganz zum schluss kam er als
sehr stark diese kampagne rot rot grün
als als schreckgespenst auch in dem
zeitpunkt ist merkel dann verstärkt in
denen bei kampf doch mit eingetreten war
das das richtige timing hätte was früher
stattfinden müssen wir schätzen sie es
einst dadurch dass sie zu wenige eigene
thematische akzente gesetzt hat sind
diese beiden trümpfe die kanzlerin ging
wirklich in den wahlkampf hat sie
gemacht hat uns alle überrascht sie hat
kann zu spät sein aber es hat sie
gemacht und es gab diese sorge vor rot
rot grün ich glaube dass wenn die cdu
von ihrem tief von 19 uhr heute abend
deutlich höher aus kommt dass das darin
begründet sein wird nur diese
strategische frage um noch mal kurz zu
den grünen zu kommen die grünen hatten
die chance die neue volkspartei der
linken mitte in dieser republik sonst
hätte eine zeitenwende werden können
dann hätte die alte tante spd ablösen
können die grünen hatten das bessere
personal zu halten dass klarere programm
und sie hatten diese großen historische
chance und wir erinnern uns ende april
28 prozent in den umfragen wenn sie
heute bei der hälfte raus kommt dann ist
das natürlich ein 1 1 guttenberg
zusammenbruch das muss man ja auch mal
feststellen und diese chance ist
verspielt und dass die spd dieses
comeback erlebt hat ihr lazarus das ist
natürlich nur dadurch zu erklären da hat
die alte die die alte marke spd hat
immer noch funktioniert daran sehen wir
auch dass seine these die volksparteien
zu früh für tot zu erklären ist falsch
ich erkläre es ja gar nicht für todt ich
sage bloß der begriff ist kommentiert
mit einer bestimmten zeit aber markant
zu machen ich halte den erkenntniswert
das war's volkspartei nicht mehr für
besonders hoch aber spannend ist doch
damals hat die grünen gesagt haben wir
können einen eigenen kanzlerkandidaten
das hat niemand gedacht das war jedem
ernstes war im bereich des möglichen
erinnern wir uns als westerwelle sich
als macher soldat erklärt den 18 an
schuhsohlen die ganze republik hat
gelacht da haben sich die verhältnisse
wirklich verändert aber warum ist es so
gekommen warum sind die grünen so
eingebrochen und vielleicht lag es daran
dass man im laufe des wahlkampfs doch
gemerkt hat die eintracht bei der
ausrufung der kanzlerkandidatin reinige
spielte eintracht die war keine echte
eintracht und in schwierigen im
schwierigen wetter- des wahlkampfes hat
die eintracht auf einmal nicht mehr
gehalten und das spürt der weiler und
die wählerinnen und glaube darauf auch
darauf sind diese für die grünen
eingebrochenen zahlen zurückzuführen
auf die afg und auch auf die linken
blicken vielleicht mal zunächst die afg
freihändig
was wir schätzen sie es ein warum hat
diese partei ist nicht so wichtig
vermocht in diesem wahlkampf ja so viele
unentschlossene waren wo so viele große
themen waren und bei der korona pandemie
auch eine große unsicherheit im land war
warum hat die partei ist nicht geschafft
zumindest wenn man jetzt den umfragen
glaubt dass stärker für sich auszunutzen
also die erste wird es anderes verkaufen
dass so viel möchte ich schon mal vorweg
sagen glaube ich wenn wir dann uns
anhören was die parteivorsitzenden zu
sagen haben dann werden sie sagen es ist
ein erfolg wir werden wieder in den
bundestag gewählt danach sieht es ja aus
wir wissen ist noch nicht aber es ist
zumindest in umfragen nach davon
auszugehen die afg hat sich konsolidiert
aber sie hat sich auch in einer relativ
bequeme sackgasse begeben würde ich mal
sagen sie zieht wieder in den bundestag
ein sie kann ein großteil ihrer mandate
behalten sie obwohl ihr großes thema
migrationspolitik gerade relativ wenige
menschen interessiert oder es nicht mehr
das haupt diskutierte thema ist und
andererseits hat sie das dürfen wir
nicht vergessen
relativ viele figuren auch verloren also
die partei hat sich radikalisiert
und nicht nur das ist haben liberale
stimmen sind verschwunden aus dieser
partei sind aus der fraktion ausgetreten
es ist ihr nicht gelungen in der korona
pandemie irgendwie einen relevanten
beitrag zu leisten sondern da war sie
anfangs noch bei den strengeren und
plötzlich ging alles zu weit also es war
unklar wo die fdp eigentlich steht und
wo es so dass die afg möglicherweise im
osten trotzdem vielleicht noch stärker
reduzieren wird als beispielsweise jetzt
die linkspartei was glauben sie
also eins muss man dazu sagen es wird
ein ergebnis wurde geben was uns
wahrscheinlich erschreckt in sachsen
oder thüringen könnte die auf die
stärkste kraft werden weil nicht weil
sie stärker wird also im vergleich zur
wahl von vor vier jahren glaube ich
nicht dass die afg in den ostdeutschen
ländern hinzugewinnen kann aber sie wird
da eben nicht schwächer und das ist auch
ein interessantes ergebnis der umfrage
die wir so sehen es wird ja nicht nur
gefragt welche partei könnten sie sich
vorstellen zu wählen sondern auch welche
partei könnten sie sich unter keinen
umständen vorstellen zu wählen und da
ist die afd auch in den starken ost
ländern wie sachsen bei um die 75
prozent das heißt sie ist insofern aus
mobilisiert als alle die sich vorstellen
können fdp zu wählen diese partei auch
wählen es gibt da aber kein
wachstumspotenzial mehr und das meine
ich mit bequemen sackgasse sie steht
ganz gut da sie wird wieder einziehen
das ist
außergewöhnlich für eine junge partei
das muss man mal so sagen aber es
gibt keinen weg stärker zu werden
aktuell und dass man dann erstmal bis
hierhin wäre sprechen gleich weiter aber
jetzt erst mal zu meiner kollegin
michaela kolster
gäste haben noch ungefähr eine
viertelstunde ist die wahllokale
schließen wobei wahllokale schließen ist
das stichwort was ich hier gerne einmal
aufnehmen möchte in berlin gab es in
einigen wahllokalen offensichtlich chaos
nicht zuletzt wegen des marathons
tapeten wahlzettel die die schnell genug
laufen nachgeliefert werden konnten
eventuell müssen die wahllokalen länger
geöffnet bleiben hat sowas schon mal
gegeben das ist schon sehr sehr
ungewöhnlicher vorgang in der tat es
scheint jetzt vor ein problem zu sein
was mit der abgeordnetenhauswahl
zusammenhängend insofern überlegt man
jetzt wohl dass die bundestagswahl erst
mal quasi vorgezogen wird diese
stimmzettel also abgegeben werden können
aber insgesamt kein gutes zeichen wir
sprechen insgesamt ja mit blick auf
briefwahl aber auch mit blick auf viele
andere facetten häufig auch davon dass
die legitimität der wahl infrage
gestellt wird gerade auch von bestimmter
seite wenn dann solche dinge noch
passieren ist es nicht sehr schön und
das sollte es eigentlich nicht geben
also ist das wasser auf den mühlen der
verschwörungstheoretiker naja zumindest
werden sie ist natürlich zu nutzen
versuchen klar wenn eine solche
unregelmäßigkeiten gibt es sinnvoll auch
falsche stimmzettel enden falsche
bezirke geliefert worden dann ist das
erst mal nicht schön das würde man sich
anders wünschen ich hoffe das lässt sich
jetzt irgendwie lösen denn wir wollen
natürlich nicht bei all dieser knappheit
von der wir ohnehin schon sprechen was
dann noch solche zweifel über die
legitimität des ergebnisses dazu kommen
dann gehen wir mal davon aus dass wir
ganz normal um 18 uhr eine prognose
haben würde gerne mit ihnen man auf
koalitionsmöglichkeiten schauen wir
haben im bund glaube ich noch nie so
viele möglichkeiten für koalitionen
gehabt wie bei diesen wahlen wenn wir
mal die umfrageergebnisse zu grunde
legen wie kommt das ja völlig richtig
wir haben wahnsinnig viele
koalitionsmöglichkeiten das liegt
einfach daran wer neben über die jahre
die in der runde gehört dass die ard
durchaus ein stabiles reservoir hat und
diese stimmen wenn sie so wollen die
fehlen für mehrheitsbildungen das macht
es für die verbleibenden parteien
einfach schwieriger genug stimmen für
eine parlamentarische mehrheit hinter
sich zu vereinen haben nicht mehr die
großen volksparteien es wäre ein wunder
wenn eine partei heute über 30 prozent
landet und all das führt einfach dazu
dass nicht mehr eine partei ganz
natürlich den regierungsauftrag hat und
dann partner um sich herum zu sammeln
versucht sondern vieles ist möglich
haben wir auch im vorfeld gehört ist
noch nicht einmal klar wer eigentlich
diese gespräche initiieren wird ganz
viel wird möglicherweise gleichzeitig
passieren wenn wir ehrlich sind wir
haben keine vorlage dafür wie diese
prozesse organisiert werden ob die
parteien erst mal paarweise sprechen ob
man da in möglichen bündnissen sprechen
wird wirklich eine hoch spannende zeit
die der vor uns liegt die wirklich
neuland ist für uns alle noch so eine
besonderheit dieser weit hat sich in den
ländern hat es ja hier und da schon
dreier konstellationen gegeben da ist
man also durchaus schon ein bisschen
übung dass man dreier konstellationen
hat aber im bund wie sie sagen als das
bisher noch nicht gegeben was bedeutet
das dann aber für die politik an sich
also eine partei die in ein
dreierbündnis geht kann natürlich noch
weniger von von ihren eigenen
vorstellungen durchsetzen ja absolut als
wenn man bei diesem modell bleibt dass
eine koalition sich eigentlich auf
gemeinsame positionen über viele viele
politikfelder hinweg verständigt dann
wird es natürlich schwieriger drei
parteien insbesondere auch entlang ganz
unterschiedlicher politik dimension
immer wieder zusammenzubringen
vielleicht wird man sich von anderes
modell entscheiden dass man bestimmte
parteien einfach er ermöglicht innerhalb
einer koalition ihre position in diesem
politikfeld durchzusetzen dann darf das
eine andere partei dafür in einem
anderen politikfeld was ihr wichtiger
ist aber auch das zeigt es werden
bestimmte herausforderungen für die art
und weise wie wir politik gestalten vor
uns liegen und dreierbündnisse wir sehen
dass in den ländern die ampel in
rheinland pfalz beispielsweise die
funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut und
trotzdem fremdeln anhänger gerade der
fdp mit diesem bündnis also insofern das
ist tatsächlich eine herausforderung
diese klare struktur es gibt lager ist
bündnisse und entlang derer form sich
koalition die liegt einfach hinter uns
aber was an die stelle tritt an
orientierung an orientierungs gebender
struktur da fehlt uns noch ein bisschen
es deutet sich an dass personen die
diese lücke füllen ministerpräsidenten
kanzlerkandidatin deswegen gewinnen sie
eben auch möglich gemeinsam bedeutung
vielen dank für den moment und wir
schauen jetzt noch mal zu unseren
kollegen in den in den wald zentralen
zuerst geben wir zu gerd joachim von
fall war eben konrad adenauer haus gab
es fühlt sich denn so langsam dass
adenauer haus und ist es immer noch
zwischen hoffen und bangen
ja es ist noch zwischen hoffen und
bangen seit 17 uhr sitzt das präsidium
hier im konrad adenauer haus zusammen
die gäste trudeln jetzt langsam ein es
sind ja viel viel weniger als bei den
vergangenen bundestagswahlen das ist
corona geschuldet allen beteiligten ist
klar dass man natürlich das ergebnis von
vor vier jahren nicht wiederholen kann
mit 32,9 prozent
ich hätte bei einer gesagt der cdu wird
schon reichen der cdu/csu wenn sie vor
der spd ein kommt und genau darum geht
es heute abend das wird ein knappes
rennen
hier im rathaus hofft man immer noch
dass man die nase vorne hat und dann mit
der regierungsbildung anfangen kann wenn
man knapp hinten liegen sollte sind die
diskussionen innerhalb der
schwesterparteien cdu und csu in den
letzten tagen ja schon sehr
durcheinander gegangen dann sagen einige
dann hat die spd den regierungsauftrag
andere sagen wenn rechnerisch zum
beispiel jamaika möglich ist dann soll
es doch armin laschet versuchen und
insofern das ist die ausgangslage hier
im konrad adenauer haus und damit weiter
ins willy-brandt-haus zuerst schäfer
dankte gerd ja zumindest hier im atrium
ist es inzwischen ja ich möchte etwas
sagen rappelvoll hätte ich gar nicht
damit gerechnet denn die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen im hinblick auf
bewohner sind jedoch sehr ausgeprägt
gewesen man kann hier nur entweder als
getesteter oder 99 erkämpfter oder
genesene rheine musste zusätzlich auch
noch einen tagesaktuellen schnelltest
machen sonst wären wir gar nicht hier im
atrium gewesen und man hat uns im
vorfeld gesagt man habe rund 500
anfragen negativ beantworten müssen also
das interesse war sehr groß hier heute
abend teilzunehmen wir haben wie gesagt
ein relativ gut und proppevolle atrium
das aber überwiegend besetztes mitte
kolleginnen und kollegen von rundfunk
fernsehen und natürlich den zeitungen
und die mitglieder und die freunde und
anhänger der spd die sie zu draußen noch
entweder im durchgang hier im willy
brandt haus oder auf dem bürgersteig an
der stresemannstraße und lassen sich
dabei bier und currywurst einigermaßen
gut gehen nichtsdestotrotz ist die
spannung hier mindestens genauso groß
wie die von der geld joachim von fallois
eben berichtet hat seit 17 uhr tagte das
um 17 uhr ungefähr tagte das präsidium
seit 17 uhr 30 ist auch der
parteivorstand hier im haus
zusammengekommen und jetzt kommt ja auch
noch die nachricht dazu dass
möglicherweise hier zumindest in berlin
die wahllokale länger öffnen können das
würde bedeuten möglicherweise das ist
auch die prognose um 18 uhr nicht gibt
also einige nerven sind hier schon
relativ gespannt ob bis zum zerreißen
wir werden es sehen einstweilen weiter
mit jeanette klag bei den grünen
auch bei den grünen hier in berlin
tempelhof in der columbiahalle da kommt
die grüne wahlparty so ganz langsam in
gang 400 gäste immerhin könnt mir in der
columbiahalle mit feiern aber es ist
eine sehr angespannte atmosphäre
schließlich ist der wahlkampf der grünen
ziemlich ins stottern geraten die
beliebtheit und die umfragewerte sind
nach unten gegangen auch durch eigene
fehler tatsächlich der grünen
kanzlerkandidaten und schließlich war
man angetreten zum ersten mal überhaupt
mit dem anspruch eine grüne
kanzlerkandidatin zu stellen und
womöglich die nächste bundesregierung
anzuführen das ganze scheint nicht mehr
sehr realistisch also erfolg und
misserfolg bei den grünen könnten heute
abend sehr nahe beieinander liegen dass
man womöglich das beste ergebnis
überhaupt bei einer bundestagswahl
erzielen könnte laut umfragen könnte das
der fall sein aber trotzdem wäre es eine
große enttäuschung weil man vielleicht
nur auf platz drei landen würde dann
würde es für die grünen nur noch um eine
regierungsbeteiligung gehen auf eine
regierungsbeteiligung hoffen aber auch
andere beispielsweise die fdp und bei
den liberalen steht meine kollegin
katharina kühn
ja und was ich hiermit bekomme ist die
stimmung hier sehr gut ich muss sagen
was ich hier mitbekommen denn wir
journalisten wir sind nur in einem
nebengebäude des hans dietrich genscher
hauses dürfen uns nicht einfach so in
die wahlparty schweißen sondern müssen
schauen wir raus kommt und mit uns redet
aber was ich da eben höre ist dass die
stimmung sehr gut ist das könnte nämlich
heute ein historischer tag für die fdp
werden denn die liberalen haben es
vorher noch nie geschafft zwei mal
hintereinander bei einer bundestagswahl
zweistellig zu werden aber mit den
aktuellen prognosen blickt man da
hoffnungsvoll auf 18 uhr die chancen
stehen ganz gut und jetzt möchte ich
gerne alexander keller fragen blickt man
dann auch bei der afg hoffnungsvoll auf
die ersten prognosen
ja vor freude würde ich ihr vielleicht
nichts sagen eher gedämpften optimismus
das ist vielleicht das richtige gefühl
dass man aus sicht der afg hier trägt
die umfragen die waren ja nicht so
prickelnd in den letzten wochen und
monaten gewesen die messlatte ist ganz
klar 12,6 prozent von der letzten
bundestagswahl wenn man runter springt
hat man ein problem wenn man darüber
kommt gilt es als politischer erfolg
dies ist wie gesagt die ausgangslage da
die zweitstimmen das
zweitstimmenergebnis für die afg
allerdings für koalitionsbildung
überhaupt nicht gebraucht wird ist es
viel interessanter für den
innerparteilichen machtkampf der jetzt
unmittelbar so wie man zumindestens an
nachdem nach der bundestagswahl ansetzen
wird ein wem hilft ein gutes wm hilft
ein schlechtes ergebnis das ist die
entscheidende frage für die afg nicht so
sehr wie es heute abend noch weiter geht
sondern wie es demnächst mit der partei
im vorfeld des bundestagswahlkampfs den
schuldigen vorstellen der bundesrat des
bundesparteitages in wiesbaden im
dezember weitergeht eines daher kann
sich die afg ganz sicher sein sie wird
die fünf-prozent-hürde weder streifen
noch reißen ganz anders als die partei
zu die wir jetzt schalten zu katja fuchs
bei den linken
genau das stimmt danke alexander kähler
hier im festsaal kreuzberg ist auch noch
eine verhaltene stimmung denn die
umfrage ergebnisse der vergangenen
wochen lagen bei 6 bis 7 prozent
die letzten sogar bei der fünf prozent
hürde auf der bühne läuft gerade ein
imagefilm noch gleich um 18 uhr wird
dort bundesgeschäftsführer jörg
schindler erwartet die
spitzenkandidatinnen janine wissler und
steht man da steht auch schon vor ort
susanne hennig welt so ist da und alle
sind sehr gespannt jetzt auf die 18 uhr
prognose dietmar bartsch hat im sommer
gesagt die küken werden im herbst
gezählt und wir sind mal sehr gespannt
welche typen bzw wie hoch die
prozentpunkte wirklich gleich um 18 uhr
sein werden und damit gehe ich weiter ab
zu meinem kollegen hans werner fittkau
bei der csu in münchen
ob es etwas zu feiern geben wird in der
csu zentrale in münchen das wird sich in
drei minuten zeigen wenn die umfragen so
eintreffen wenn daraus tatsächlich ein
wahlergebnis wird dann wird auch in
münchen viel nachgedacht werden müssen
über die gründe man kann es dann
möglicherweise nicht auf armin laschet
alleine abwälzen es wird dann
wahrscheinlich auch eine diskussion
geben über die
unterstützungsaktionen aus münchen ob
ist so klug war drei wochen vor der wahl
ein interview im spiegel zu geben wo der
generalsekretär der csu sagt armin
laschet wäre nicht der richtige sondern
markus söder wäre der besser keine
bessere kandidat gewesen das wird sich
dann zeigen es gibt ein
worst-case-szenario hier für die csu in
bayern das sieht nämlich so aus die csu
kommt nicht über die fünf prozent hürde
sondern in den bundestag zieht sie nur
ein durch die gewonnenen direktmandate
und dieses worst case szenario würde
noch gesteigert wenn es den freien
wählern die gibt es ja auch noch wenn es
den freien wählern gelingen würde hier
in bayern 33 direktmandate zu gewinnen
und so in den bundestag zu kommen also
wie dieser abend hier aussieht das steht
noch in den sternen respektive einen
prognosezahlen jetzt gleich aus berlin
kommen und dorthin gebe ich jetzt zurück
vielen dank an es werner fittkau maaß
wir haben noch eine minute 20 so
ungefähr ich würde das gern ein bisschen
aufnehmen was hans werner fittkau gesagt
hat also ist droht dass die csu nicht
unbedingt über die fünf-prozent-hürde
bundesweit tatsächlich kommt das hat
aber letztendlich für die csu doch gar
keine großen auswirkungen oder ein
exaktes gibt zwei möglichkeiten wie man
mit voller stärke mit vollem
zweitstimmenanteil in den deutschen
bundestag einzieht wenn man entweder
fünf prozent der zweitstimmen bundesweit
bekommt oder das ist funktional
äquivalent also den konsequenzen
identisch wenn ich mindestens drei
wahlkreise gewinne auch dann ziehe ich
mit voller zweitstimmen stärker ein und
das wird für die csu auf absehbare zeit
immer eine garantie sei der
bundespolitischen anspruch der geht ein
stück weit verloren ja natürlich es gibt
zwei neuralgische punkte für die csu sie
droht vielleicht unter 30 prozent zu
rutschen in bayern sie droht unter die
fünf prozent dann das weite rutschen das
ist nicht der anspruch den csu hat an
sich und das macht es auch für markus
söder durchaus gefährlich denn er ist
bisher nicht derjenige der der csu
insgesamt tolle wahlergebnisse geholt
hat insofern werden wir möglicherweise
heute abend auch ein stück
schuldzuweisungen zwischen union oder
zwischen cdu und csu sollte man sagen
sehen vielen dank soweit es sind also
nur noch wenige sekunden bis 18 uhr
gleich werden wir ins zdf wahlstudio
schalten um dort die prognose zu hören
natürlich wie bei phoenix immer kriegen
sie bei uns auch die zahlen der ard die
werden wir dann im insight für sie
aufrufen so dass sie die zahlen von zdf
und ard haben und ich würde jetzt mal
sagen wir gehen mal rüber
jetzt die prognose für die
bundestagswahl
cdu/csu 24 prozent sehr deutliche
verluste schlechtestes ergebnis bisher
spd 26 prozent deutliche gewinne afd
zehn prozent verluste fdp 12 ähnlich wie
vor vier jahren linke 5 fast halbiert
grüne 14,5 deutliche gewinne andere
zusammen 8,5 jetzt hintereinander weg
zunächst in berlin die prognose der
forschungsgruppe wahlen sieht die spd
bei 23 prozent leichte gewinne cdu 17
prozent ähnlich wie 2016 grüne 22
prozent deutliche gewinne linke 14
prozent leichte verluste afd
6,5 mehr als halbiert fdp acht leichte
gewinne andere zusammen
9,5 und die prognose für das land
mecklenburg vorpommern die spd kommt auf
39 prozent sehr deutliche gewinne afg 17
prozent verluste cdu 14 verluste linke
zehn verluste grüne 6,5 leichte gewinne
und im landtag und die fdp mit 6 prozent
deutlichen gewinnen und wahrscheinlich
auch wieder im landtag die anderen
zusammen 7,5 prozent so das ist die
grundlage für den weiteren abend alle
prognosen
wir kehren zum bus zurück was bedeutet
die prognose für die sitzverteilung für
mögliche koalitionen das alles jetzt
ausführlich von matthias fornoff ja und
bettina bevor wir auf die sitzverteilung
gucken und die möglichen konstellationen
damit wir keinen völligen zahlensalat
hier anrichten erst mal zur erinnerung
noch mal die prognose für die
bundestagswahl
schritt zu weit standen wir müssen das
noch mal zurück holen da ist sie die
prognose für den bundestag da sehen wir
die sehr großen verluste von union
deutliche zugewinne bei spd und grünen
und jetzt schauen wir mal auf die
sitzverteilung im neuen deutschen
bundestag und da sehen wir dass die
union auf 198 sitze käme die spd auf 215
afd 83 fdp 99 linke 41 und grüne 120 wir
haben es in der prognose aber gesehen
wir haben die linke bei genau fünf
prozent es kann also auch sein dass sie
nicht mit rein kommt deshalb haben wir
eine zweite grafik hier da hätten wir
dann 7 121 sitze insgesamt da käme die
cdu csu auf 200 spd 217 a r steht 83 fdp
100 und grüne 121 das wie gesagt wenn
die linken an der fünf-prozent-hürde
scheitern würden und jetzt gucken wir
auf die möglichen
regierungskonstellationen die sich
daraus ergeben hier ist die senkrechte
linie hinter der liegt die absolute
mehrheit die man braucht eine koalition
aus spd und union käme auf 413 sitze und
würde das schaffen spd und grüne union
und grüne jeweils nicht und jetzt sind
wir bei dreierbündnisse spd grüne und
fdp würden das deutlich schaffen 434
interessant spd grüne und linke also rot
grün rot würde es sogar dann nach
derzeitigem stand knapp verfehlen diese
absolute mehrheit wenn die linken denn
drin wären und zuletzt union grüne fdp
jamaika also 417 das würde auch reichen
dankeschön matthias so also die spd
führt in der prognose der
forschungsgruppe wahlen 26 zu 24 für die
union
das ist nah beieinander und das kann
sich natürlich im laufe des abends auch
noch noch enger gestalten ja vielen dank
so weit die zahlen des zdf bei der ard
liegen die spd und die union sogar
gleichauf und wir gehen gleich mal zu
unserem kollegen erhard scherfer er hat
wie ist die stimmung in der spd und wie
werden die zahlen dort aufgenommen
das ist ganz interessant michaela
kolster weil im moment ist es
vergleichsweise ruhig obwohl es im
atrium des willy-brandt-hauses
relativ voll geworden ist
zwischenzeitlich jetzt brandet jubel
hinter mir auf und ich kann ihnen
ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz genau sagen
worauf die menschen im atrium jetzt
reagieren es sind tatsächlich jetzt auch
viele mitglieder hier reingekommen und
auch anhänger der spd was sie jetzt
gerade aktuell bei jungen wie gesagt
kann ich wenig ganz genau sagen offenbar
wird jetzt über die großen monitore eine
weitere prognose vorgestellt vorhin gab
es hier nur die prognose des zdf und der
name der jubel dann soko april zu haben
am lautesten wurde als erste ergebnisse
über sehen bis jetzt auch noch mal
bisher erste prognosen kamen wir in
mecklenburg vorpommern da war es hier
natürlich ganz besonders laut und danach
hat man offensichtlich angefangen nach
zu bringen und auch noch mal abzuwarten
aktuell in diesen sekunden bleibt jetzt
wieder rhythmisches klatschen eingesetzt
aber das gilt ganz offensichtlich einem
interview dass hier geradezu gespielt
wird mit lars klingbeil auf der anderen
seite ist man hier wahrscheinlich und
nach wie vor gespannt darauf wie es sich
jetzt tatsächlich weiter entwickelt denn
diese zahlen die wir eben gesehen haben
die sind gerade an einem wahltag wie
heute und gerade mit den zahlen die sie
präsentiert worden sind ja noch nicht so
ganz aussagekräftig deswegen werden wir
uns wahrscheinlich das eine und andere
mal hier noch mal wieder melden müssen
michaela
damals tatsächlich noch wieder hören das
ist ja auch gut so und ich frage gleich
aber meinem kollegen gerd joachim von
fallois
ein kopf an kopf rennen so ist es nach
wie vor wie sieht es bei der union
ja wir stehen hier im wintergarten die
kameras deswegen haben wir nicht so viel
einsicht in das eigentliche fest zählt
aber ich glaube wir haben dort auch
bilder eingefangen es war hier sehr
ruhig als die prognose vorgelesen wurde
es gab noch einmal massiv applaus als
dann festgestellt wurde dass ein rot rot
grünes bündnis im moment zumindest nicht
funktionieren würde es ist sehr knapp
aber die cdu hat natürlich lange nicht
das ergebnis eingefahren mit dem man
hier heimlich gehofft hatte es geht ja
darum eigentlich die nase vor der spd zu
behalten das scheint vielleicht nicht
zuklappen nun liegt die letzte hoffnung
auf den briefwählern die traditionell
eigentlich er immer ein bisschen mehr zu
cdu csu und fdp tendieren das bleibt
abzuwarten jedenfalls kann das hier auch
noch ein langer abend werden die
hoffnung dass man doch noch an der
regierungsbeteiligung beteiligt wird die
hat man hier jedenfalls bei den zahlen
noch nicht aufgegeben und damit weiter
hat zustande clark bei den bündnisgrünen
vielen dank von hier in der
columbiahalle in berlin tempelhof da war
der jubel als das erste prognose kam
tatsächlich lauter als diese prognose
für die grünen ist tatsächlich vermuten
lässt denn wenn die prognose ungefähr
zutreffende ist bei um die 15 prozent
dann wäre das eigentlich schlechter als
fast alle umfragen die grünen zuletzt
gesehen hatten und wenn man in die
historie zurück schaut den letzten zwei
jahre lagen die grünen in umfragen
konstant über 20 prozent teilweise ja
sehr weit über 20 prozent also zuletzt
bei 14 15 prozent in umfragen zumindest
mitte 2018 also 15 prozent dieser jubel
der war zwar sehr demonstrativ aber man
hatte sich natürlich völlig anderes
erhofft man hat eine grüne kanzler
kandidaten ins rennen geschickt mann
hatte den anspruch zum ersten mal
vielleicht überhaupt die kürzung
kanzleramt auf stoßen zu können
das sieht nach dieser prognose überhaupt
nicht so aus ganz im gegenteil die fdp
ist sogar relativ nah die grünen noch
heran die rutsche am lautesten übrigens
war der jubel hier in der columbiahalle
als die erste prognose für berlin kamen
denn da liegen nach den prognosen die
grünen sogar vor der spd und könnte
womöglich die regierende bürgermeisterin
dann stehen und natürlich war man dann
hier sehr euphorisch tatsächlich also
wir werden das ergebnis später einordnen
natürlich mit gästen hier am set wollen
jetzt aber erst mal weiterschauen zur
fdp dort steht katharina kühn
ja und die fdp die chance jetzt ziemlich
konzentriert auf das ergebnis als ist
dann kam für ihre partei gab es dann
auch applaus allerdings jubel würde ich
das nun nicht nennen aber dabei hat die
fdp das geschafft was sich in den
umfragen angedeutet hat elf bis zwölf
prozent so sieht es momentan aus hat sie
erreicht ist damit auch wieder nicht
klappt eben schon gesagt hat sehr nah an
die grünen herangekommen also man kann
sagen das konzept der fdp im wahlkampf
was sie verfolgt haben nämlich wirklich
auf eigene inhalte zu setzen sich nicht
an eine koalition zu schmieden das es
aufgegangen und man wird natürlich noch
sehen wie sich das ergebnis mit den
wählerstimmen aus der briefwahl
verändern wird da könnten sich ja auch
noch einige verschiebungen ergeben aber
was auf jeden fall schon mal deutlich
wird es könnte zu einem eben
historischen ergebnis kommt zweimal
hintereinander in einer bundestagswahl
zweistellig und damit zu alexander
keller bei der afg
ja mei der afg hat man relativ positiv
reagiert auf das bundestagswahlergebnis
zehn beziehungsweise elf prozent das
hätte schlimmer kommen können ist
allerdings weniger im moment zumindest
diesmal der prognose als das
bundestagswahlergebnis
2017 jubel ist hier ausgebrannt einmal
als man das historisch schlechte
wahlergebnis der union auf bundesebene
bekannt gegeben hat und das
offensichtlich auch an die links
koalition aus spd grünen und der partei
die linke auf bundesebene nicht möglich
ist ansonsten hat man natürlich auch den
wahlerfolg in mecklenburg vorpommern
gefeiert zweitstärkste partei 18,5
prozent in der prognose dass es mehr als
man dort erwarten konnte also bei der
afg im moment alles etwas durchwachsen
im bereich und diese 10 11 prozent auf
bundesebene die liga genau in dem
korridor wo man jetzt über
interpretation und überbewertungen was
kann das für die partei für die
verschiedenen parteiflügeln bedeuten
würde ich ausschreiben kann als sie so
hat das wahlergebnis vielleicht noch
keine klärung gebracht das ist
allerdings die prognose wie es
tatsächlich ausgeht werden wir sehen und
damit zu katja fuchs zu den linken
genau hier ist die stimmung sehr
schlecht gewesen es gab ein lautes als
die fünf prozent verkündet worden sind
und viele entsetzte gesichter weil damit
hatte man nicht gerechnet man hatte doch
gedacht dass man weiter von der 5
prozent hürde entfernt ist zweistellig
das war eigentlich mal der wunsch jörg
schindler hat dann auf der bühne auch
noch mal gesagt es liegt nicht an uns
wir haben zusammengestanden haben einen
tollen wahlkampf gemacht aber scheinbar
ein wahlkampf der nicht die wählerinnen
und wähler angesprochen hat und es wird
ein langer abend werden hier bei der
linken denn es stellt sich die frage
bleibt ist bei den fünf prozent wird es
vielleicht sogar noch weniger werden
dann wäre die frage nach direktmandaten
die einzige möglichkeit noch in den
bundestag zu kommen auch die
koalitionsfrage über die an den
vergangenen wochen immer wieder geredet
wurde rot rot grün das sieht im moment
nicht danach aus dass heißt sagt
weiterhin sehr spannend und sehr
ernüchternd die bühne hinter mir ist
schon wieder leer die meisten leute sind
auch draußen gerade und das glaube ich
über dieses ergebnis
erst mal miteinander sprechen und damit
gebe ich ab zur csu und hans werner
fittkau nach münchen
vielen dank katharina kühn auch bei der
csu hat sich der saal hier schon ein
bisschen geleert worden was man vorher
als die ersten zahlen gaben jetzt sind
einige csu-anhänger die hier in der
parteizentrale anwesend sind
rausgegangen draußen ist etwas besser in
sachen corona ja zu handeln ist eine
schöne und warme abend hier in münchen
hier drinnen wurde ist wollen erstmal
still als die erste prognose zahlen hier
kamen gerade von der ard 24 5 24 5 beide
große parteien und es wurde dann richtig
laut als die zahlen für bayern kamen die
csu legt nämlich laut prognose des
bayerischen rundfunk bei 33 prozent das
würde sehr wahrscheinlich reichen um aus
eigener kraft die fünf prozent also mit
der kraft der zweitstimmen die fünf
prozent hürde zu überwinden und in den
bundestag einzuziehen man wäre dann
nicht auf die direktmandate angewiesen
denn das war so ein worst case das eine
horrorvorstellung hier die csu in bayern
dass man aus eigener kraft nicht in den
bundestag kommt und wie gesagt eben nur
über die direktmandate fast die führung
zu diesem ergebnis zu sagen hat es wenn
wir dann im laufe des abends hören
markus söder ich vermute dass er die
parole ausgibt die csu hat in bayern
trotz dieses kandidaten der cdu des
kanzlerkandidaten armen armin laschet
der sehr unbeliebt war und ist in bayern
trotzdem ist es der csu gelungen auf 33
prozent zu kommen das sind zwar immer
noch rund fünf prozent weniger als bei
der letzten bundestagswahl in bayern
aber ich vermute eben dann wird die
devise ausgeben wir sind dadurch mit
einem blauen auge davon gekommen das
werden wir im laufe des abends hören und
ich gebe für den moment zurück nach
berlin
vielen dank an hans werner fittkau an
auch an alle korrespondenten vieler
stimmungsbild aus den parteizentralen
der professor fest wenn wir jetzt vor
allem die zahlen von ard und zdf nehmen
da sind wir ja eigentlich fast genauso
schlau wie vorher vor 18 uhr aber in die
richtung geht das kann man
ehrlicherweise stand jetzt nicht sagen
wenn wir auf den boden schauen wenn wir
auch auf die beiden landtagswahlen
schauen die prognosen die davor liegen
unterscheiden sich bemerkenswert doch an
vielen stellen zwei punkte zwischen den
instituten teil bei sogar noch mehr das
deute darauf hin dass es auch für die
demoskopen ein schwieriger wahlabend ist
und das wiederum heißt es kann ein
langer wahlabend werden also da kann
auch eine menge bewegung in die zahlen
kommen muss sogar denn am ende muss ein
ergebnis da stehen das sind heute
wirklich 18 uhr zahlen die wir noch mit
ein bisschen mehr vorsicht hat sonst
vielleicht genießen müssen der
generalsekretär in der spd lars
klingbeil hat es schon mal die
regierungs ist die regierungsfähigkeit
betont und hat gesagt wir haben auch den
regierungsauftrag ist das nicht ein
bisschen früh
erstmal ist es ja ein schillerndes
konstrukt dieser regierungsauftrag das
können ja immer alle parteien sehr gut
wähler aufträge regierungsaufträge als
solchen wahlergebnis nur auszulesen
formal ist es erstmal ganz offener punkt
am ende braucht eine kanzlerin ein
kannst du eine mehrheit im deutschen
bundestag klar lars klingbeil wird sich
eher auf die zahlen aus dem zdf berufen
haben zwei prozentpunkte wäre schon ein
abstand mit dem man argumentieren kann
es gab ja auch signale aus der csu im
vorfeld dass man aus dieser position
heraus nicht den kanzleranspruch wird
aufrechterhalten können aber trotzdem
wenn man ehrlich ist es dafür eigentlich
heute aber noch viel zu früh und formal
gibt es einen solchen regierungsanspruch
oder auftrag nicht zu verstehen uns das
kann man glaube ich heute jetzt eine der
wenigen sachen die man schon sagen kann
das wird auch nach diesem wahlabend
spannend wie es weitergeht schauen wir
einmal auf die zahlen die die ard hat in
ihrer prognose da kommen wir haben es ja
schon gesagt cdu und spd gleichauf 25
afd und fdp auf elf prozent linke 5 auch
da knapp die grünen bei 15 also bei den
kleineren unterscheidet sich nicht so
deutlich aber bei den beiden größeren
cdu csu und spd ist es eben ein kopf an
kopf rennen um nochmal darauf einzugehen
regierungsanspruch ja oder nein
letztendlich ist es ja so dass die
koalition entscheidet es muss auch nicht
unbedingt die größte fraktion nun die
fraktion sein die den kanzler stellt
nein keineswegs diese regel kennt das
grundgesetz nicht und es gibt ja auch
historische beispiele genau dafür dass
nicht die stärkste fraktion den kanzler
gestellt hat könnte auch in 2011 in
baden württemberg denken den der beginn
der ära kretschmann würden manche sagen
da hat 25 prozent die cdu hatte damals
in baden württemberg 37 prozent und
trotzdem war völlig klar dass die union
die cdu in baden württemberg abgewählt
war jetzt geht es darum mehrheiten zu
finden stabile mehrheiten zu finden das
ist vielleicht schon ein signal dass man
aus diesen ersten prognosen herauslesen
kann selbst wenn es für rot grün rot
reicht dann wäre das eine wirklich sehr
sehr sehr knappe mehrheit ich glaube
nicht dass olaf scholz sich darauf
einlassen würde also insofern für rot
rot grün ist das glaube ich das würde
ich jetzt schon fast mutig sagen doch
ein schwieriger also hat die kampagne
der cdu an der stelle gegriffen ja das
ist schwer zu sagen denn es gab
natürlich auch ein strategisches
interesse von wählerinnen und wählern
der linken die nicht weiß oder sondern
von wählerinnen und wählern die gerne
eine linke politik hätten das ist
möglicherweise sinnvoller ist zu olaf
scholz der spd zu wechseln das war
schwierig für die linke aus dieser
position heraus stärke zu zeigen stärke
zu gewinnen aber das ist tatsächlich
eine frage wie wird man in der
wählerwanderung auch nochmal sehen im
mindesten hat diese rot-rot-grüne
kampagne glaube ich die eigenen anhänger
und anhänger auf seiten der union
stabilisiert denn schon eine weile war
das jedoch ein ziel was armin laschet
den blick nehmen musste und da war diese
kampagne sicherlich erfolgreich vielen
dank für diese erste analyse und ich
gebe abzuwenden und ich bin mal gespannt
was die korrespondenten zu sagen haben
ja ich glaube man kann an diesem abend
auf jeden fall sagen dass es sich lohnt
phoenix zu gucken weil wir ja die zahlen
sowohl von lb als auch von zdf zeigen
und die er genau in diesem spannenden
punkt jetzt noch unterschiedlich sind ja
frage in die runde was sagen sie zu
diesem ja noch nicht stand ich finde es
gibt ein stand also die erste erkenntnis
es gibt keinen klaren regierungsauftrag
für keinen der beiden großen parteien
wenn die so dicht beieinander liegen
kann keine aus dem wahlergebnis ableiten
sagen ich muss kanzler werden es kommt
jetzt auf die geschicklichkeit an
mehrheiten und koalitionen zu
organisieren die zweite erkenntnis ist
die am meisten diskutierte
koalitionsfrage der letzten drei wochen
droht rot-rot-grün oder kommt rot rot
grün die haben die wähler beantwortet
dass es offensichtlich die kombination
die keine chance hat oder keine chance
haben soll insofern haben wir zwei
gemengelagen die welle die süßen und die
saure drops man den parteien ziemlich
gleichmäßig verteilt es gibt keine
partei die heute abend durchgängig
zufrieden ist oder die durchgängig frau
ist ein erster vermutlich noch die spd
vielleicht sollten wir uns das wort
regierungsauftrag schlichtweg streichen
nicht nur wegen des wahlergebnisses
sondern das grundgesetz kenne das gar
auftrag des regiert derjenige der eine
koalition zustande kriegt und der die
stimmenzahl erreicht die den
bundeskanzler wählt und da wir uns jetzt
auf die geschicklichkeit von laschets
oder schweiz ankommen
wir haben das kann man feststellen eine
herbe niederlage der cdu csu und diese
niederlage ist nicht alleine die schuld
von laschet die ist auch schuld daran
ist auch söder man hat oft von den
sticheleien geredet schließlich das wort
sticheleien ist ja milde in der
staatskanzlei in münchen steht keine
stichelei maschinen also steht eine
riesige nähmaschine die in vielen
interviews
tatsächlich gegen den gemeinsamen
kandidaten gesprochen hat und zwar fast
den ganzen wahlkampf lang das heißt die
niederlage ist die gemeinsame niederlage
der beiden parteivorsitzenden und jetzt
kommen eine zweite feststellung die
glaube ich schon wichtiges laschet ist
noch nicht verloren auch wenn er wenn
die cdu/csu verloren hat also bei uns
genau das was eben thematisiert
alle anfangen also sondieren ich
bewundere den mut bayer kollegen doch
schon relativ apodiktisch zu sprechen
ehrlich gesagt wäre ich jetzt sehr sehr
vorsichtig mit mit steilen thesen weil
wir jetzt die nächsten stunden auf auf
rohen eiern und zwar dünnen schale
kronen tanzen werden denn diese zahlen
die geben außer dass in der tat
niederbayerische krachende niederlage
für die union geben diese zahlen keine
grundlage auf der man irgendwie
besonders steil gehen könnte allerdings
wenn es sich verfestigen sollte dass die
zahlen die das zdf jetzt erhoben hat in
der prognose stimmen dass also der
abstand da 2% plus x-fi leicht sogar
sein wird dann wird es armin laschet
sehr schwer haben diesen zu reklamieren
dass er auch eine sich um eine koalition
bemühen kann das hat sie mir aber eben
schon angekündigt
auch die cdu sondieren möchte und in
richtung jamaika geblickt frau hennig
natürlich die cdu sucht ihr heil jetzt
im regieren wenn sie nicht regieren
könnte stünde sie relativ blank da das
sagen viele in der partei wenn der
katastrophe für sie wenn sie nach dem so
ein schwaches ergebnis erzielt hat jetzt
auch noch in die opposition muss ich
finde aber nachdem auch die lage so
unklar ist können wir eines schon
ziemlich genau sagen nämlich dass sich
mindestens drei parteien in ihrem
eigenen selbstbild korrigieren müssen
das selbstbild der cdu war auch nach
angela merkel werden wir stärkste kraft
davon sind die vest ausgegangen armin
laschet hat gestern beim
wahlkampfabschluss in aachen noch gesagt
weil sie heute hier ist er meinte angela
merkel die warme da wird es morgen auch
gelingen das heißt irgendwie hat die cdu
gehofft die beliebtheit dieser kanzlerin
könnte sich übertragen lassen auf die
ganze partei ist zeigt sich jetzt
die cdu brauchen richtigen neustart ohne
angela merkel des zweiter selbstbild was
korrigiert werden muss die grünen haben
gedacht sie sie seien in der nähe der
kanzlerschaft davon sind sie weit
entfernt und das dritte selbstbild ist
das von der spd die es selber überhaupt
nicht für möglich gehalten hat noch vor
zwei monaten ins kanzleramt einzuziehen
das hat er darauf hätte niemanden eine
flasche wein gewettet und jetzt ist es
so weit dass es so passieren könnte das
finde ich sehr spannendes ergebnis der
wahl jenseits davon wäre dann am ende
zwei oder drei prozent aber bisher nicht
nur aus der langen perspektive zu
interpretieren sondern auch aus der
kurzen natürlich ist es so dass die cdu
sehr verloren hat in der langen
perspektive aber vor 14 tagen fühlte
sich die cdu bei 19 prozent war aus dem
rennen man dachte nur noch wie wird
jetzt sozusagen der machtkampf und heute
abend ist die situation da das lasche
kanzler werden kann das ist natürlich
auf einmal ein gefühlter kleiner sieg
innerhalb des großen dramas der union
ich weiß ich also das bisschen an
gerhard schröders aufholjagd als er am
ende dann doch knapp unterlegen war und
es in der elefantenrunde in der
legendären aber auch noch nicht einsehen
wollte dass das dem so sei wohl auch
weil immer noch mal nicht ganz
zutreffend
umfragezahlen oder in zügen
ergebniszahlen zugerufen und also dass
das jetzt bei der union glücksgefühle
auslöst stadt mit 19 prozent mit diesen
25 ticks nach hause zu gehen das
bezweifle ich habe
gehe ich doch ein riesiges teil also
wenn es so ist
es fällt mir schwer ist nichts zu tun
das kann man halt auf die füße fallen
dann ist es halt so aber wenn dann
tatsächlich der abstand zwei
prozentpunkte plus ist zwischen spd und
union dann würde ich mir die frage
stellen oder
stellt sich die frage ob armin laschet
überhaupt noch irgendetwas verhandelt
also dann wird es für herrn laschet
glaube ich ganz ganz eng überhaupt den
parteivorsitz nicht kleine gegenrede das
ganz ganz kurz bevor er zur gegenrede
kommen was man auf jeden fall ja schon
weiß ist dass die grünen in berlin auf
jeden fall den sieg davon getragen haben
und uns liegt ein interview vor mit
anton hofreiter
wenn wir da vielleicht mal kurz das
ergebnis ist erfreulich aber wir hätten
uns mehr erwartet
und ich danke einfach erst mal unseren
wählerinnen und wählern und unserem
ganzen wahlkämpferin gold kämpfen und
insbesondere sind spitzenkandidaten
annalena baerbock und hubert rhomberg
aber
erfreulich nehme ich eben nicht ganz so
haben die grünen lagen die letzten
beiden jahre eigentlich in umfragen
konstant über 20 prozent das
wahlergebnis war wieder schlechter als
die umfragen beziehungsweise auf die
letzten umfragen sagen sie über ungefähr
auf diesem niveau wo man sagt es
wie gesagt es ist dort zum spiel wales
und ich habe gesagt wir haben uns mehr
erhofft und ich glaube dass man erst mal
abwarten muss wie die zahlen am ende
wirklich ausschauen noch sind die zahlen
sehr schwankend und dann werden wir
sehen in berlin zb freuen wir uns dass
wir hoffentlich stärkste partei geworden
sind aber die zeit sagen dass die grünen
wahrscheinlich zehn prozent hinter cdu
und millionen liegen was ist das für ein
auftrag für eine mögliche
regierungsbildung für die grünen
es ist wir sehen es als auftrag das
beste aus dem ergebnis zu machen und
dafür zu sorgen dass am ende klimaschutz
rauskommt dass euro pro zusammengehalten
wird dass die gesellschaft
zusammengehalten wird und wie das am
ende sozusagen ausläuft glaube wird es
ein sehr langer abend welche spd und
union sind ja irgendwann einander
auch wenn die beiden wir uns sehr nahe
beieinander liegen ist könnte ja auch
darauf hindeuten dass die möglichkeit
die vorne liegen zu
sondierungsgesprächen zu ersten
gesprächen einladen
wir haben gesagt wir schließen nichts
aus aber es lohnt sich erst mal
abzuwarten wie das ergebnis wirklich ist
aber wie sinnvoll wären parallele
gespräche mit spd und mit union
das hat jetzt erst mal für reine
spekulation schauen wir mal wir haben
ende vorne liegt
wie weit wäre der weg in die ampel oder
jamaika für die grünen mit diesem
ergebnis
für uns ist entscheidend dass eine
progressive regierung raus kommt die
wirklich auf augenhöhe mit den problemen
agiert und das heißt wir müssen wirklich
jetzt dafür sagen das pariser
klimaschutzabkommen 1 2 wir müssen das
noch erlebt haben in papua panometer
besonders wir endlich eine vernünftige
digitalisierung haben wir müssen die
spaltung unserer gesellschaft angehen
wir müssen europa stärken das ist das
entscheidende dass keine regierung mehr
des kleinsten gemeinsamen nenners gibt
soweit anton hofreiter bei den grünen
und wir gehen gleich weiter in die
spd-zentrale zu erhard scherfer der hat
den generalsekretär das klima
so ist das vielen dank lars klingbeil
ist bei uns herr climie mal was können
sie einschätzen beim jetzigen stand der
dinge was wie würden sie den jetzigen
stand hätte bewerten die spd es zurück
so das ist das klare signal des heutigen
abends wir waren vor ein paar wochen
abgeschlagen auf platz drei wir hatten
13 14 15 prozentpunkte und jetzt stehen
wir auf eins und das ist etwas wo wir
uns sehr darüber freuen dass die
wählerinnen und wähler uns das vertrauen
schenken das 400.000 spd-mitglieder
gekämpft haben in den letzten wochen
darüber bin ich sehr glücklich dass mit
dem platz eins ist im moment noch eine
etwas gewagte these denn wir haben wenn
man es mal im fußball vergleichen
betrachten noch nicht mal halbzeit ja
aber wir sehen ja dass der rote balken
hoch geht und dass der schwarze balken
sehr weit runter geht also der auftrag
an olaf scholz eine regierung zu bilden
der ist ja eindeutig da die menschen
wollen dass olaf scholz der nächste
kanzler dieses landes ist aber wir haben
noch nicht mal eine hochrechnung um
diese uhrzeit sondern wir haben
prognosen das heißt es ist noch nicht
eine einzige briefwähler stimme
wahrscheinlich eingeflossen in die
zahlen die wir da gesehen insofern ist
ihre these jetzt vielleicht auch ein
bisschen kühl also wir freuen uns über
den rückhalt den wir haben wir sehen die
spd war vor ein paar wochen noch auf
platz 3 jetzt sind wir vorne das zeigen
haben das zeigen die ersten zahlen jetzt
veröffentlicht wurden und jetzt warten
wir mal den rest des abends ab aber ich
bin sehr optimistisch dass es klappt wie
waren denn die bewertungen die es im
vorstand und dem präsidium gegeben hat
zwischen 17 und 18 uhr lagen diese
zahlen ja durchaus auch schon vor tagen
ähnliche zahlen vor wir haben uns
gefreut alle haben sich bei olaf scholz
bedankt der einen fulminanten wahlkampf
geführt hatte hat die partei gezogen in
den letzten wochen 400.000 mitglieder
die mit ihm unterwegs waren wir haben
gesehen die plätze waren voll das
interesse an der sozialdemokratie war da
also wir haben uns gefreut wir waren
dankbar und jetzt warten wir mal den
abend ab das ist ein knappes rennen das
haben wir immer gesagt aber ich bin mir
sicher am ende liegt die spd vorne weil
sie die prognosezahlen ebenso gefeiert
haben was würden sie denn mit diesem
prognosezahlen für eine regierung
veranstalten wollen ich sage immer
schärfer heute wird ein bisschen
gefeiert wir freuen uns über das
comeback der spd und morgen werden wenig
gremien beraten wie es weiter geht
sanders welche während welche
koalitionsmöglichkeiten würden sie den
unter den gegebenen bedingungen sofern
sie sich verfestigen überhaupt für
denkbar halten sie haben wir darauf
hingewiesen wir müssen den haaren
abwarten die wissen noch gar nicht
welche koalition möglich sind aber heute
haben wird gefeiert morgen wird geguckt
wie wir eine stabile regierung zusammen
kriegen wir sehen uns morgen früh wieder
vielen dank für ihre im moment geht
zurück ins wahlstudio
ja soweit erhard scherfer und lars
klingbeil herr fast schauen wir mal wir
haben die grünen und auch die spd gehört
bei den grünen hat man die enttäuschung
anton hofreiter auch wenn er versucht
hatte das schön zu reden doch ein stück
weit an gesehen ist das nicht sogar das
größte scheitern was wir heute abend
sehen nämlich bei den grünen auch wenn
sie eigentlich zugelegt haben aber
letztendlich haben sie das mega thema
klima was in der luft liegt und was
eigentlich das thema des wahlkampfs sein
sollte nicht nach hause gebracht liegt
das an fehlern bei der grünen spitze
sicherlich ist der absturz bei den
grünen sehr groß weil man die kampagne
insgesamt sich anschaut insofern wird
man da auch sehr kritisch drauf gucken
eben insbesondere auch weil das
thematische umfeld eigentlich sehr sehr
günstig war auch wenn man an diese
monaten wochen zurückdenken als die
kandidatin präsentiert wurde welche
euphorie das ausgelöst hat wie gut
orchestriert die kampagne rezipiert
wurde das alles hat sich nicht
bewahrheitet und natürlich annalena
baerbock war eine vergleichsweise
unbekannte politikerin sie hatte damals
einen bekanntheitswert von 66 prozent im
land und das bedeutet eben dass da kein
aus definiertes image da war und als
dann all diese vorwürfe gekommen sind
nebeneinkünfte plagiat et cetera das
buch das hat sich einfach
niedergeschlagen in ihrer person und da
wir einen sehr personenzentrierte
wahlkampf insgesamt hatten konnten die
grünen dem eigentlich nichts
entgegensetzen trotz des thematisch
guten umfeld also insgesamt wieder mal
so eine grüne kampagne die nicht
wirklich am ende geliefert hat sprechen
gleich noch über die spd weiter aber wir
gehen jetzt erst mal zu meinem kollegen
gerd joachim sohn verlor der hat mich
ziemlich den generalsekretär der cdu
so ist das bauwerk ist zu mir gekommen
er klinge bayern hat gerade gesagt das
sei ein klarer regierungsauftrag für die
spd weil die union ja so viele
prozentpunkte verliert das ist ein
argument das man immer wieder hört was
jetzt in sie dem entgegen der abend ist
noch ganz jung wir werden einen langen
wahlabend erleben und es ist so wir
wissen nicht wer am ende die nase vorn
haben wird wir haben jetzt auch nur
aufholjagd erlebt der union gerade in
den letzten tagen und den letzten beiden
wochen und am ende wird es um die frage
gehen wer kann ein gutes bündnis für
deutschland schmieden darum wird es
gehen klar die verluste sind schmerzhaft
für uns aber für uns geht erst das land
dann die partei es gibt zwei
möglichkeiten nach den umfragen nach den
prognosen jetzt einmal ein schritt
zurück in die vergangenheit rot grün
wieder diesmal mit stimmen der fdp oder
ein starkes zukunftsbündnis für
sicherheit stabilität aber eben auch
klimaschutz und innovationen zwischen
union grünen und fdp es kommen ja noch
die auswahl der briefwähler da ist die
union eigentlich immer traditionell ganz
stark wie wichtig wäre es denn für herrn
laschet und die cdu/csu dass sie vorne
liegt jede stimme zählt und deswegen
haben wir auch um jede stimme gekämpft
aber das wollen wir jetzt abwarten es
ist noch sehr früh am abend
kopf-an-kopf-rennen jetzt niemand kann
sicher voraussagen wie der abend endet
aber er hat sie mich noch mal wenn die
wir für millionen war jede stimme also
wenn sie mich fragen finden sie es gut
wenn die briefwähler ja natürlich
natürlich hoffe ich auf jede chance aber
wenn die union auf platz zwei landet ja
dann wird doch das argument kommen man
hat ohnehin so viele prozente von 32,9
verloren dann ist man nur zweiter dann
hat man den regierungsauftrag nicht naja
also sie sehen jetzt kopf-an-kopf-rennen
deswegen kann niemand von einem klaren
regierungsauftrag sprechen das ist klar
die spd reklamiert dass
würde ich an deren stelle tun weil sonst
ist es eben nicht so eindeutig ist doch
logisch es geht am ende um die frage wer
kann eine gute zugriffs koalition für
dieses land bilden und darüber muss man
sprechen und darüber muss man verhandeln
und wir sind dazu bereit abschließend es
war eine richtige achterbahn man könnte
ja sagen schon vor ein paar tagen 19
prozent ist das jetzt ein erfolg dass
man wieder nach oben gekommen ist aber
sie als generalsekretär als
wahlkampfmanager sind sie nicht durchaus
enttäuscht 25 prozent hatten sie mit
nicht mit mir rechnen müssen also unser
ziel war ein anderes ist doch ist doch
klar und ich bin es ist bitter und es
tut auch weh wenn man die verluste sieht
im vergleich zur letzten bundestagswahl
wo wir viel stärker waren und das müssen
wir auch aufarbeiten und ich finde das
darf man auch nicht schönreden
da gibt es an diesen verlusten gibt es
nichts schön zu reden aber das andere
ist diesem land zu dienen und die frage
ist kriegt man eine zukunft koalition
hin oder nicht und darüber werden wir
sprechen vielen dank dass sie mir klar
dass meine damen und herren der
generalsekretär der cdu bei den
momentanen ergebnisprognose kann man
noch nichts sagen festzustellen bleibt
jedenfalls dass die cdu/csu natürlich
nicht das ergebnis von vor vier jahren
erreichen wird das war hier jedem klar
die frage ist hat man die nase vorne
oder nicht kann man einfluss nehmen auf
ein jamaika-bündnis bin dann zu einem
jamaika-bündnis zu gründen oder nicht
das ist die entscheidende frage ja aus
sicht des konrad-adenauer-hauses wenn
sich die zahlen des zdf verfestigen
sollte man liegt 2 3 4 prozentpunkte der
spd dann wird das hier ein ganz anderer
abend werden als wenn die cdu csu nach
wie vor die chance hat den
regierungschef zu stellen und damit
zurück zu michaela kolster vielen dank
gerd und paul signac bleiben wir mal
kurz bei der cdu und auch bei armin
laschet der musst du nun im vorfeld erst
mal um den parteivorsitz kämpfen dann
musste er um die kanzlerkandidatur
kämpfen und jetzt geht er mit minus 8
prozent nach hause das sieht nicht
besonders gut aus wenn sich tatsächlich
der abstand wie beim zdf um 2 3%
verfestigt zugunsten der spd kann er
dann überhaupt parteivorsitzender
bleiben
dieses ergebnis wird durchaus auch
disziplinierend in den parteien wirken
weil natürlich stehen jetzt schwierige
koalitionsverhandlungen bevor und in die
will man sicherlich nicht geschwächt
einziehen mit einer unklaren
personalsituation also diese
unsicherheit könnte für armin laschet
sogar ihm ein wenig zeit bringen ein
wenig auch ruhe bringen denn klar ist
das haben wir gerade auch im statement
von kojima gehört es wird in jedem fall
schwierig egal selbst wenn der vorsprung
knapp wird ein argument zu finden warum
die union in den regierungs oder in die
sondierung gehen wird und ich glaube
insgesamt dass bei allen unterschieden
die wir in den parteien sehen und in
schwierigen situationen die wir auch in
den statements schon gehört haben dass
trotzdem die unklare situation wer
handelt jetzt eigentlich mit wem welches
koalitionsabkommen aus dass das
insgesamt durchaus disziplinieren wird
so wie wir das eigentlich aus
wahlkämpfen kennen da heißt es zusammen
zu stehen so gilt es jetzt vielleicht
auch für diese phase von sondierungs und
koalitionsgespräche wenn wir auf laschet
schweren stand noch mal schauen kann man
da auch rückblickend sagen dass er
merkels werk und so dass beitrag
zumindest haben die beiden ihm das leben
nicht leicht gemacht nicht zuletzt
deswegen weil ihre umfragewerte einfach
viel viel besser waren und damit war
immer klar irgendwie hat man aus dieser
trias den schwächsten zum
kanzlerkandidaten ausgewählt und von
dieser bürde wenn man so will konnte man
oder konnte er sich auch nie frei machen
ich fand es ganz interessant bei zehn
jahre jetzt schon die strategische
kommunikation los gibt jamaika ist das
zukunftsbündnis die ampel ist der
schritt zurück in die vergangenheit rot
grün plus fdp wird spannend sein was wir
so an bildern jetzt hören was eigentlich
die vorzüge der einzelnen koalition sind
schauen wir noch einmal auf die fdp wir
haben ja eben auch lars erklingen weil
er gesagt der eben wenn er die roten und
schwarzen balken sieht bei den verlust
beziehungsweise bei den gewinn
rechnungen dann sieht er einen ganz
großen roten balken und deswegen ist es
natürlich ganz klar dass olaf scholz der
neuer kanzler werden soll aber so
einfach ist es dann ja letztendlich
nicht wenn wir uns die die spd mal
anschauen ist das so eine art
gegenmodell zur union es gab eine ganz
frühe festlegung auf den
kanzlerkandidaten
man ist zumindest nach außen hin
geschlossen aufgetreten
aber das ist ja eine geschlossenheit in
der spd eigentlich gar nicht gibt oder
weil sie hat es gegeben
bemerkenswerterweise aber klar ist auch
der spd so hat man zumindest erwartet
stehen schwierige entscheidungen bevor
wenn es jetzt wirklich dazu kommt aber
es wirklich noch sehr früh gerade dass
dieses rot grün rote bündnis vom tisch
ist dann wird das unglaublich
diszipliniert für die spd wirkung weil
dann ist klar eigentlich ist die ampel
wirklich die einzige chance für die spd
den kanzler zu stellen das kanzleramt
zu erobern und dann stellen sich diese
debatten eigentlich gar nicht wo wollen
wir denn hin würden wir gerne nach links
würden wir gerne zur mitte hin insofern
wäre das für die disziplin und die
geschlossenheit der spd durchaus auch
eine etwas vereinfachende situation da
muss jemand noch mal nachfragen ob das
wirklich so disziplinierend wirkt weil
wir haben eine eher linke partei führung
und wir haben dann einen eher
bürgerlichen olaf scholz das sind ja
zwei flügel in einer partei die man so
schnell nicht zusammenbringen kann man
könnte auch sagen hat vielleicht die
eher linke politik führungen spd-führung
eine art bürgerlich trojanisches pferd
eingeschleust mit olaf scholz nein das
ist richtig natürlich sind diese
inhaltlichen unterschiede nicht
plötzlich weg nur wenn das die
bündnisoption fehlt dann werden sich die
linke natürlich in der halb inhalte spd
zweimal überlegen ob sie die beiden die
opposition gehen oder ob sie nicht dann
doch eine ampel koalition unterstützen
aber trotzdem natürlich das sehen wir an
allen faktor in allen parteien auch
heute abend dass die frage wo wollen wir
denn eigentlich hin sind wir eine partei
die für die ampel offen ist am beispiel
der fdp oder wollen wir unbedingt
jamaika da wird natürlich auch jetzt
hinter den kulissen heftig gerungen
insofern ist es eigentlich nur so ein
zwischenschritt heute abend auf dem weg
hin zur positionierung der parteien und
erbrecht zur bildung von koalitionen
aber überall kommt die fdp mit vor da
müssen wir auch gleich noch darüber
reden aber zunächst einmal geben wir zu
meinem kollegen alexander kähler der
gruppe h bei der afg hat
kompalla knapp über der 10 prozent
grenze für die afd ist ihnen das zu
wenig es ist ja weniger wie es aussieht
als bei der bundestagswahl 2017 ist also
erst mal ein sehr solides ergebnis ist
man erstmal konstatieren wir haben
unsere stammwähler gehalten davon kämen
mittlerweile ausgehen sicherlich hätten
wir uns ein zwei prozent mehr gewünscht
das würde ich überhaupt nicht verhehlen
dass ermotti nächsten stunden natürlich
noch anschauen nächsten tage anschauen
aber insgesamt war unser ziel wieder mit
einer starken opposition in den
bundestag einzuziehen wenn sich erinnern
an die aussagen vor 2017 wieder von den
parteien kam die optimus reihe ist die
dürfe nie wieder in den bundestag kommt
das ziel ist nicht erreicht worden und
wir haben ein starkes hier wir werden
bei der strecke oppositionspartei im
bundestag seien immer 2017 angekündigt
das nächste mal wenn wir noch stärker
das wird jetzt wohl nicht passieren geht
dieses ergebnis dann auch mit ihnen als
verantwortlichem spitzenkandidaten nach
hause wir müssen uns mal insgesamt
anschauen wenn wir uns die die
parteienlandschaft anschauen haben ja
eigentlich auch die großen volksparteien
zb die cdu stark verloren und wir hören
uns sicherlich anschauen warum wir davon
nicht profitiert haben aber wir sehen
dass diese wählermilieus wie sie
vielleicht noch vor 15 jahren vorhanden
waren das ist starker block parteien
gibt die gibt es de facto nicht mehr und
das hat sich aufgeteilt also wir werden
sicher nicht analysieren woran es
gelegen hat ob an unserer kampagne
vielleicht was falsch war oder
vielleicht nachjustiert werden müssen
vielleicht müssen wir auch mehr
antworten geben das würde ich ganz klar
sagen weil die wähler natürlich erwarten
wie soll ein deutschland unter uns
aussehen und das wären bei den nächsten
tagen natürlich auch in besprechen warum
sie auch neue themen flüchtlinge zieht
nicht mehr so warten wir mal die
nächsten monate und jahre ab wir werden
denke ich die nächsten monate über den
preisschock in deutschland reden über
die inflation über die steuerung über
die renten über die steuerpolitik die
themen liegen eigentlich auf der straße
es gibt auch uns gab auch in diesem
wahlkampf nicht ein emotionales thema
sondern mehrere es gab auch regionale
unterschiede zwischen ost und west
zwischen nord und süd und dass wir über
die nächsten tage uns anschauen und
woran es gelegen hat ich habe in der
partei ein burgfrieden während des
bundestagswahlkampfs zwischen ihnen und
ihrem co vorsitzenden jörg merten
zwischen den leuten und dem heckflügel
bricht da jetzt der machtkampf wieder
auf was bedeuten dann so prozent zahlen
um die zehn für diesen machtkampf sind
sie geschwächt sie gestärkt
wissen sie ich bin im friedliebender
mensch und ich beteilige mich an
machtkämpfen und alles andere
entscheidet bei uns die parteibasis und
es wird der parteitag im dezember zeigen
so weit guido knopp aller der
spitzenkandidat der afg für dich zu
interviewen danke dass sie da waren ja
vielen dank an alexander keller schon
immer auf die fdp fast zehn prozent die
ein bett sehen die anderen sehen die
umfrageinstitute zurzeit die afd ist das
wählerpotenzial damit ausgeschöpft so
sieht es aus aber zugleich heißt es eben
auch dass selbst in einem schwierigen
umfeld die afg auch auf zehn prozent
kommen kann insofern wären erwartungen
dass die partei kurzfristig verschwindet
wirklich naiv muss man sagen ja ist er
ja sicherlich versucht in dieser
legislaturperiode ihr ihren
anspruchsvollen zu verbreitern mit blick
auf die klimaleugner auch natürlich mit
blick mit blick auf querdenken oder
ähnliches das hat nicht wirklich
gefruchtet aber trotzdem stand heute
auch mit spitzenkandidaten die kaum
jemand kennt im land zumindest grob
aller wenn man sich seine
bekanntheitswerte etwa im
deutschlandtrend der ard anschauen all
das führt nicht dazu dass die parteien
nicht trotzdem zehn prozent der stimmen
bekommt das scheint tatsächlich doch ein
sehr stabiles reservat zu sein was wir
hier sehen woran hat es letztendlich
gelegen die afg kennt ja bei den letzten
wahlen immer nur den weg nach oben und
hat steigende zahlen gehabt fehlten die
themen auch ein stück weit bei corona
konnte die öfter nicht so richtig
realisieren flüchtlingskrise ist zurzeit
zwar vielleicht irgendwann mal in ein
paar jahren in sicht aber zurzeit nicht
fehlten da die themen es fehlte das
thema was für die afg tatsächlich sehr
zentral ist nämlich in der tat die frage
von zuwanderung flüchtlingen gab diese
kurze zeit als dass die situation in
afghanistan gab die auch die mediale
agenda sehr dominiert hat wo man
durchaus hätte erwarten können dass die
afb davon noch mal profitiert aber auch
dass es nicht passiert insofern muss man
wirklich sagen das scheint so eine
verfestigte form von unzufriedenheit zu
sein die wir dort sehen bei der afd die
auch relativ unabhängig zu sein scheint
von themen von personen aber das
limitiert sind natürlich auch
offensichtlich auf diese etwa zehn
prozent trotzdem macht sie damit den
anderen parteien das leben natürlich
schweren und auch unabhängig gegenüber
den flügelkämpfen die er in der fd
massiv stattfinden ja absolut wir haben
ja sehr sehr breite debatten auch an der
stelle gehört mit blick auf beobachtung
durch den verfassungsschutz mit blick
auf betrachtung wer sitzt eigentlich für
die achte eben deutschen bundestag dass
da auch wirklich rechtsextreme dabei
sind all das schadet ihr nicht wirklich
ist nutzt sie auch nicht aber es schadet
die auch nicht das scheint wirklich so
ein fester kern zu sein mit dem wir uns
doch auf absehbare zeit jetzt werden
engagieren müssen
erstmal vielen dank und wir gehen weiter
zu der linken dort ist jörg schindler
der bundesgeschäftsführer was auch ein
generalsekretär ist im interview was war
das für ein gefühl als ich die 5 prozent
prognose gehört naja natürlich sind wir
enttäuscht
es ist ein schwerer einfach für die
linke ist so lange für uns ein harter
weckruf dass wir jetzt über die um die
fünf prozent kämpfen was ist klar und
das ist natürlich auch bei uns einen
einen wirklich ein starkes ein starker
weckruf darüber dass wir gucken müssen
woran es denn jetzt gelegen hat ist es
klar dass wir als partei zusammenstehen
müssen denn eins ist auch klar wir
wollen diese gesellschaft verändern wir
wollen eine soziale alternative
darstellen wir wollen eine ökologische
und auch eine antirassistische
alternative darstellen und offenbar
hätten wir uns in der vergangenheit die
eine oder andere diskussion geschenkt
aber das ist eine sache die müssen wir
in ruhe und solidarisch gemeinsam
diskutieren die eigene diskussion
beschenkt das spiel stimmen sie auf die
vielstimmigkeit innerhalb der linken an
oder dass man nicht ein fokus gewählt
hat und dass man das gelassen dann auch
nicht in wähler der wählerinnen
vermitteln konnte was man wirklich
möchte oder dass ich es so dass wir eben
gucken müssen wie wir in der
vergangenheit als performance die wir
daraus waren und da gab es bestimmt sehr
viel luft nach oben die vielstimmigkeit
haben sie angesprochen da müssen wir
natürlich raus wir müssen klarmachen
wofür die linke steht das haben wir im
wahlkampf ja auch getan trotzdem
wahlkämpfe sind natürlich das eine die
wahlkämpfe werden aber in den jahren
davor entschieden und das hat der linken
jetzt offenbar auch geschadet stichwort
vergangenheit ich die vergangenen
landtagswahlen zuletzt sachsen anhalt
schlager hab schon eklatante verluste
brandenburg und rheinland-pfalz
baden-württemberg haben sie versucht
hereinzukommen das heißt sie hatten ja
eigentlich genug potenzial jetzt in den
vergangenen jahren zu gucken wie
schaffen wir es dass wir die 92 prozent
der vergangenen bundestagswahlen
konzerns halbiert da schaut sie wir sind
eine partei im massiven umbruch wir sind
eine partei die etwa ein fünftel ihrer
mitgliedschaft in den letzten
zweieinhalb jahren hinzu aber auch
verloren hat jedes fünfte mitglied bei
uns ist neu in den letzten zweieinhalb
jahre und klar ist auch dass wir in
diesen jahren natürlich auch
mitgliederverluste insbesondere im osten
haben hinnehmen müssen das ist teil von
fehlender verankerung die wir dort jetzt
auch in den wahlergebnissen spüren das
ist richtig aber uns bleibt ja nichts
anderes übrig wir brauchen da eine
veränderung wir brauchen da einen
schritt nach vorne den haben wir in den
letzten jahren als partner auch gegangen
und da müssen wir jetzt natürlich
konsequent bleiben und da müssen wir
auch klar machen wofür wir als linke
sozial ökologisch antirassistisch stehen
gefühl sie hatten jetzt zuletzt die in
wochen rot-rot-grün da war immer wieder
da hatte man das gefühl man kann zum
ersten mal mitregieren
jetzt sieht er momentan nach der ersten
prognose noch so aus dass das nicht so
ist wie enttäuscht sind sie naja
natürlich bedeutet das ein rückschlag
für eine reform option weil logisch ist
doch rot grün hat keine mehrheit das hat
es auch wieder gezeigt und nur mit der
linken wird es einen konsequenten
politikwechsel geben würde es ein
schluss mit der politik der verlorenen
zeit der letzten 16 jahre geben wir
können so nicht weiter
unsere wirtschaftsweise betreiben wir
müssen sozial anders denken wir müssen
so ökologisch anders handeln und dafür
haben wir als linke vorschläge gemacht
wir wollten den mindestlohn erhöhen wir
wollten auch die mieten decke wir wollen
natürlich auch eine soziale
grundsicherung hartz 4 endlich endlich
abschaffen das gibt es ja immer noch und
das ist natürlich ein rückschlag
erlitten das sind die leidtragenden die
bürgerinnen und bürger in der tat so und
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer sie
haben es gemerkt mit der ersten
hochrechnung hat ein bisschen gedauert
wegen der auszählung der
briefwahlstimmen aber jetzt ist es
soweit und es wird die erste
hochrechnung vor
wenn sie denn nicht in den bundestag
kommt sieht das so aus union 200 spd 217
sitze afd 83 fdp 100 und grüne
121 was hieße das für mögliche
koalitionen im bund
die absolute mehrheit liegt bei
379 und wir sehen spd und cdu/csu bei
413 das würde also reichen spd und grüne
reicht dann doch jetzt relativ deutlich
sie sehen das bild wir haben 24 7 für
die union und wir haben 24 9 für die spd
also denkbar knapp wirklich ein stand
von dem man eigentlich noch gar nichts
sagen kann außer dass es für armin
laschet und die union wirklich herbe
verluste sind was bedeutet das für die
zukunft von armin laschet
ich glaube die zukunft von armin laschet
entscheidet sich heute abend und in den
nächsten tagen die mieter lage hat die
cdu csu erfahren sie kann man auch hier
an den
ergebnissen hochrechnungen ablesen der
zweite teil der niederlage hängt davon
ab wie sich die parteien cdu und csu
verhalten wenn jetzt das große
schlachtfest beginne dann wäre die
geschichte für laschet zu ende man kann
sich nicht vorstellen dass ein
kanzlerkandidat der aus der partei
heraus attackiert und gemeuchelt wird
noch weiter die verhandlungen führen
wird dann würde es heißen die partei
geht in die opposition und wenn ich die
ersten stimmen diesbezüglich schon vor
dem wahltag gab es solche stimmen aus
bayern wenn wir nicht die stärkste
fraktion stellen müssen wir die frequenz
zu unterbrechen herr prantl weil von der
union kommt zwar niemand aber wir sehen
bei den grünen annalena baerbock und
robert habeck
[Applaus]
hallo schön gut dass wirklich außen sind
auf dem markt setzen und ein paar mehr
leute mit dabei sein
erst mal
großartig berlin bettina muss sie ja
schon los aber die zahlen sind ganz ganz
wunderbar herzlichen glückwunsch auch
wenn wir noch nicht wissen wie das
endergebnis ausgegangen ist großartig
berlin und auch was wir aus mecklenburg
vorpommern sicher heute abend
gleich ein von mir ich könnte jetzt
nur stellvertretend für unsere 120.000
mitglieder hier stehen danke euch allen
danken raus in die republik wir haben
ein wahlkampf gemacht gespürt wie wir
ihn noch nie in diesem land erlebt haben
rund um die uhr bis gestern nacht letzte
sekunde waren so viele unterwegs wir
haben über 100 town holz gemacht mit
tausenden von menschen die vorbereitung
dafür tag und nacht von euch danke diese
town holz das war wirklich großartig und
wollen die da wo wir gemeinsam auftreten
könnten
zwar immer die besonderen momente vor
ort zu sein abends in frankfurt oder zum
abschluss in düsseldorf
und dabei so viele menschen zu spüren
die gar keine grünen mitglieder waren
sondern ganz viele interessierte wo man
gespürt hat da gibt es eine sehnsucht
nach politischer debatte und vor allen
dingen der sehnsucht nicht von
denjenigen die schon 40 50 60 jahre alt
sind sondern drittklässler viertklässler
nicht nur auf den scheiß for future die
muss sondern auf den veranstaltungen bei
uns wir haben eine freistunde wir sind
vorbei gekommen weil wenn man hören
wollten das bei euch eigentlich los ist
da zu hören wir können jetzt zu armin
laschet gehen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
liebe
freundinnen und freunde
das ist heute ein ganz besonderer
wahlabend
zum ersten mal
seit 16 jahren
hat angela merkel nicht mehr als
bundeskanzlerin
kandidiert das waren 16 gute jahre für
deutschland und deshalb gilt mein erster
dank der bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
für ihre arbeit
aber
und zwar klar
und zwar klar ohne amtsbonus wird dass
ein offener ein harter ein enger
wahlkampf und so ist es auch gekommen
es ist ein kopf an kopf rennen dieser
wahlabend ist eine ausnahme situation
wir haben derzeit noch keine gesicherten
endergebnisse keine gesicherten zahlen
aber wir können jetzt schon sagen mit
dem ergebnis können wir nicht zufrieden
sein
und trotzdem der ausgang der wahl ist
noch völlig unklar es wird ein langer
abend und in jedem fall stellt das
wahlergebnis
deutschland die union
alle demokratischen parteien vor große
herausforderungen
wir müssen die weichen stellen für die
20er jahre
das kann keine partei alleine und
deshalb bedarf es jetzt einer großen
kraftanstrengung aller demokratinnen und
demokraten
wir müssen gegensätze überwinden und
deutschland zusammen halten es wird
erstmals
aller voraussicht nach eine
bundesregierung mit drei
bündnispartnern geben können und wir als
union haben von unseren wählerinnen und
wählern einen klaren auftrag erhalten
eine stimme für die union ist eine
stimme gegen eine links geführte
bundesregierung
und deshalb
deshalb werden wir alles daran setzen
eine bundesregierung unter führung der
union zu bilden denn deutschland
deutschland
deutschland braucht jetzt eine zukunfts
koalition die unser land modernisiert
deutschland braucht eine koalition für
mehr nachhaltigkeit in jeder hinsicht
beim klimaschutz und bei den finanzen
wir tragen verantwortung für die
künftigen generationen
für unsere kinder und enkel und dieser
verantwortung müssen wir stärker gerecht
werden als bisher gerade beim
klimaschutz wir brauchen eine koalition
die unser land schneller macht und
digitalisiert dass unser land von
fesseln befreit und bei plan und
genehmigungsverfahren mehr tempo
ermöglicht wir brauchen eine koalition
die für weltoffenheit steht und für
marktwirtschaftliche lösungen eine
koalition die europa stärkt und die
gemeinsam mit den gleichgesinnten
demokratien in der welt die
herausforderungen der zukunft
gestaltet eine koalition die einen
beitrag leistet für eine bessere welt
dafür werde ich
dafür
dafür werde ich ab jetzt arbeiten
gemeinsam mit markus söder gemeinsam mit
unserem gesamten team und in dieser
koalition
muss sich jeder partner wiederfinden
muss sich jeder mit seinen schwerpunkten
wiederfinden es muss eine koalition
werden die das land zusammenhält und in
der jeder
auch das umsetzen kann was er seinen
wählern versprochen hat ich gratuliere
allen wettbewerbern zu ihren
wahlergebnissen und danke für einen
wahlkampf der fast immer fair war vor
allem danke ich euch alle den wal
kämpferinnen und wahlkämpfern von cdu
und csu von nord und süd von ost bis
west das war ein gelungener and spruch
das war eine große aufholjagd ihr habt
großes geleistet die ab nie aufgegeben
und das ist auch mein antrieb das ist
unser antrieb für die zukunft
der wahlkampf
der wahlkampf ist vorbei jetzt geht es
um 1 eine stabile koalition für ein
starkes und modernes deutschland und
bundeskanzler wird der dem es gelingt
gegensätze zu verbinden und ein gutes
gemeinsames programm für die nächsten
vier jahre zu entwickeln
ein bundeskanzler
bundeskanzler wird der der im deutschen
bundestag genau diese gegensätze
überwindet eine mehrheit findet der
jetzt gewählten abgeordneten überall im
land und es muss ein bundeskanzler sein
für alle die in deutschland leben das
ist die aufgabenstellung die vor uns
liegt es wird viele intensive
fachgespräche mit den politischen
wettbewerberinnen und wettbewerbern in
den nächsten tagen geben
dieser bundeskanzler muss ein projekt
entwickeln das länger trägt als nur die
nächsten wochen eine wichtige
wahlperiode liegt vor uns zu dieser
aufgabe bin ich bereit
ja so weit zu armin laschet im
konrad-adenauer-haus hermann armin
laschet so hört ein sehr kämpferische
armin laschet das hätte man sich im
wahlkampf vielleicht an der einen oder
anderen stelle sogar gewünscht dann
möchte man meinen dass die union hier
klarer wahlsieger ist ist sie aber nicht
da stehen immer noch minus acht prozent
im vergleich zur letzten bundestagswahl
auf der uhr kann er denn diesen anspruch
überhaupt tatsächlich für sich
reklamieren wenn man bedenkt dass es
vielleicht ja doch so eine art
wechselstimmung ist bei minus acht
prozent oder in der tat das wird
spannend sein wie man genau mit seinen
persönlichen umfragewerten auch umgeht
denn die sind wirklich schlecht das muss
man sagen bei den direktwahlfrage da
kann wirklich sehr sehr deutlich hinter
olaf scholz erkämpft das merkt man sehr
deutlich und erholt sich hier natürlich
auch implizit die zustimmung der partei
lässt sich bejubeln auch ein stück weit
da kann die parteien jetzt nicht stehen
lassen wenn er sagt ich bin bereit und
er versucht natürlich auch das was er
als person auch als ministerpräsident
von nordrhein-westfalen immer wieder
anführt dass er dinge zusammenführen
kann dass er integrieren kann das war ja
das motiv seiner seiner wenigen worte
die er hier gewählt hat spannend ob das
verfahren wird aber er ist auf jeden
fall nicht bereit zurückzuziehen sondern
im gegenteil er wirkt jetzt sehr
offensiv in diesen wenigen worten so
weit erst mal zu armin laschet und wir
gehen dann gleich weiter zur fdp denn da
ist christian lindner der vorsitzender
der fdp
[Applaus]
daher wird es schlimmer
wir lieben vielen dank
vielen dank
meine sehr geehrten damen meine herren
liebe parteifreundinnen und